Bonsoir.
Bonsoir
Caroline Galactéros. Bonsoir. Nous
sommes sur une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle Syerview. Nous sommes en
direct. Nous vous recevons dans le cadre
de votre capacité à faire de la
géopolitique, de l'analyse, de la
prospective. Est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succintement ?
Oui, succintement. Donc [grognement] je
suis j'ai une formation littéraire et
d'histoire. Puis après, je suis allée
vers les sciences politique. J'ai passé
mes 10 premières années
de travail intensif au sein des services
de l'État dans un organisme qui
s'appelle le secrétariat général de la
défense nationale et là j'étais chargé
de l'évaluation de la prospective du
conflit Yougoslave. Donc c'était la
décennie 90 en gros. J'ai quitté fin
2001.
Donc après le Kosovo, après tout ça,
j'ai un peu enseigné à un peu à normal
supérieur et quelques années à CHC, les
questions internationales stratégiques,
la gestion de crise et puis je me suis
consacrée à ma douce famille.
[grognement]
Mais évidemment, sans jamais cesser de
réfléchir, d'essayer de comprendre, je
suis ensuite rentrée en 2004 dans la
réserve opérationnelle des armées, dans
l'armée de terre.
Euh j'ai fait l'Idn
euh la 59e promotion
et puis et puis voilà, je me suis mise à
petit à petit à ressortir après quelques
années le bout de mon nez et à
m'intéresser de plus en plus à un
certain nombre de sujets. J'ai enseigné
aussi à l'école de guerre les questions
d'éthique, de moral et de conflit
pendant 4 ans.
Collège interdé de défense à l'époque. à
l'époque. Ouais. Cid, voilà, qui est
redevenu l'école de guerre quelques
années plus tard.
Et
et je me suis mise à écrire de manière
publique, en fait, vraiment publique,
au-delà de quelques revues spécialisées
à partir de 2015. On m'a proposé d'avoir
une petite tribune dans [grognement] le
point que j'ai appelé état d'esprit,
esprit d'état.
Et puis après, de fil en aiguille, au
gré euh des événements malheureux sur le
sol français notamment, euh quelques
médias euh se sont intéressés à ce que
je pouvais donner comme analyse sur
divers sujets, pas seulement de la
géopolitique
lointaine, euh mais évidemment la
résonance sur des événements intérieurs,
notamment de sécurité
euh et des liens que je faisais que
d'autres peut-être faisaient moins
volontiers.
[grognement]
Et donc voilà, c'est comme ça que je me
suis mise à intervenir en essayant en me
disant que petit à petit je pouvais
peut-être espérer
faire réfléchir un peu différemment aux
enjeux géopolitiques qui pour moi sont
des enjeux [grognement] euh en fait
quotidien ordinaires qui touchent nos
concitoyens. Enfin la géopolitique c'est
dans votre assiette quoi. On la vit, on
l'a subit.
Vous avez décidé d'assumer la présidence
d'un sing qui s'appelle Géopragma. Oui.
Euh vous avez créé ça il y a environ un
an et demi, un an.
Oui, une bonne année. Ou une année.
Euh le vous avez un comité d'éthique, un
conseil d'orientation, quelque chose qui
qui compose ce S tank. Quel est le but
de ce S tank ? Est-ce que vous vous le
décrivez comme un action tank ?
Oui, ben c'est-à-dire que je voudrais
faire quelque chose d'un peu nouveau qui
à mon avis n'existe pas en France. Il y
a des sing tank en France très installés
que je connais très bien avec des gens
très bien à l'intérieur qui
réfléchissent mais je pense que
malheureusement on est dans une espèce
de système de résonance de de caisse
d'éco
de [soupir]
d'un d'une pensée. Moi, c'est une doxa.
C'est une manière de voir et d'expliquer
et même d'analyser les questions
internationales
qui malheureusement de mon point de vue
n'est plus du tout adapté un à la
situation internationale de à celle de
notre pays trois à nos intérêts
nationaux et donc j'ai eu cette idée au
bout d'un moment je me suis dit bon tu
es toute seule mais en fait tu n'es pas
toute seule gens comme moi qui qui ont
cette même vision très pragmatique très
réaliste de de la réalité intern
international réaliste mais pasynique,
c'est précisément l'inverse, mais
j'espère qu'on en reparlera.
Et donc il faut il faut faire je dirais
pas de la contreinfluence mais il faut
créer un pôle de réflexion et d'action
c'est-à-dire et de de véritables
recommandations opérationnelles
alternatif à tout ce qui existe parce
que tout ce qui existe c'est une pour
moi une [soupir]
une fausse diversité si c'est-à-dire
tout ça c'est un peu la même chose bien
sûr avec des des inflexions mais il y a
quand même voilà on est on est pour moi
très loin de notre ADN stratégique il Il
s'agit donc de le retrouver. Il s'agit
de faire évoluer l'écosystème
stratégique français d'abord mais aussi
européen et évidemment international.
Donc pour y participer, il faut faire
masse [grognement] et il faut faire
masse. Donc je me suis dit, je vais
essayer d'agréger petit à petit, ce
n'est pas une masse à faire, des gens
qui soit n'osent pas, soit se disent que
ça ne sert à rien, soit sont un peu
frustrés, un peu désespérés, souvent
marginalisés aussi quand ils sont un peu
trop indépendants dans leurs idées,
trop politisés
ou trop politisés, certains bien sûr.
enfin il y a toutes sortes de de cas de
figure et donc ensemble euh créer
quelque chose qui se mett à compter et à
compter aussi à l'international parce
que finalement si on regarde si on prend
une planète et qu'on regarde aujourd'hui
mais bien sûr il y a des milliers de
sing tank consacrés à la géopolitique
sur la terre mais si on en prend
quelques-uns dans chaque grand pays en
je sais pas aux États-Unis en Angleterre
en Allemagne même en Europe en Italie en
Russie bon en France,
qu'est-ce qu'on a pour répondre si vous
voulez ? Donc moi, je voudrais faire
quelque chose de qui qui petit à petit
compte, voilà, et qui participe au débat
et qui participe à transformer la
réalité non seulement institutionnelle,
non seulement à infléchir notre
politique étrangère, à à proposer
d'autres choses, mais aussi qui
participent au débat international
stratégique.
Je vous une parenthèse.
Vous parlez euh de contreinfluence. Oui.
Est-ce que les sing français s sont sous
influence et sous influence de qui, par
qui et comment ?
Euh oui, je pense que c'est une forme de
contre-influence qu'il faut faire, mais
l'influence n'est pas un gros mot, hein.
C'est comme euh c'est comme les rapports
de force, c'est juste le la matière
première de la réalité internationale.
Donc bon,
je pense oui que peu ou prou, sans même
s'en rendre compte forcément, ça n'est
pas forcément conscient ou délibéré,
bien sûr nos tanks comme certaines
parties même de notre de notre appareil
institutionnel sont sous influence. Oui.
Alors, quelle influence ? Bah, bien sûr,
c'est une influence
en fait atlantiste qui qui vient du fait
qu'on on se pense et on se vit. et on
agit euh en permanence avec l'idée qu'on
ait une une extension euh de la
politique américaine. Or, si l'Amérique
est notre grand allié, c'est pas ça que
je conteste. Il y a une identité, il y a
une singularité, il doit y avoir une
indépendance de la pensée politique et
stratégique française comme allemande,
comme italienne et cetera. Après, il
faut en faire quelque chose peut-être à
l'échelle européenne, mais ça n'est
certainement pas en se stérilisant, en
se fossilisant et en se niant qu'on va
arriver à garder et à même à retrouver
au stade où on en est une place et un
rôle dans les bouleversements
géostratégiques qui sont en cours et qui
nous attendent pas. Voilà.
Vous vous avez une expérience dans
certains S tank. Oui.
Est-ce que Est-ce que les S tanks ne
sont pas devenus des lieux où les gens
se rencontent pour côtoyer le bourgeois,
se faire un réseau, se faire bien voir,
arriver à toucher des marchés ? Oui, il
y a tout ça bien sûr, il y a cet
aspect-là mais bien sûr, mais il y a
aussi des il y a aussi des très bons
chercheurs. Il y a aussi il y a aussi
des des gens qui qui ont une capacité de
réflexion, d'analyse, de lucidité, de
doutes, euh qui ne sont pas prisonniers
eux-mêmes du dogmatisme. problème, c'est
que la matière sing tank, elle est bien
sûr sous les feux euh de
ce ce ce terrible virus qui nous a saisi
après la fin de la guerre froide, qui
est une espèce de de moraline, de
moralisation de tout et n'importe quoi
en matière internationale. Et non
seulement c'est absolument inefficace
opérationnellement, mais en plus c'est
faux. C'est-à-dire c'est c'est c'est
contre contre tout, contre temps, contre
productif, contre emploi euh et
contradictoire profondément. Donc c'est
pour ça que j'aime parler de morale et
d'hique parce que pour moi c'est pas du
tout la même chose en en en politique
internationale. La morale ben bien sûr
elle est elle est tenue et contrôlée par
la politique donc par des paris-je
des contingences. Chaque pays a son idée
du bien, du mal vrai, du bon, du juste,
de l'opportun, du nécessaire. Bon,
l'éthique c'est autre chose. L'éthique
c'est une manière peut-être de penser
son action internationale. Si on le voit
collectivement, je parle même pas de
l'éthique propre et je parle pas de la
déontologie, c'est encore un autre
sujet. Mais c'est une façon de pouvoir
inscrire sa pensée, son action. Ça ne
veut pas dire mépriser ses intérêts. Au
contraire et surtout dans le cas
français où nos intérêts sont très liés
à nos valeurs et on devrait pas les
opposer. Mais nos valeurs, c'est pas
juste des grands mots. Il faut qu'on
arrête de confondre le verbe et
l'action, de s'imaginer que le verbe
fait action, ça ça ne marche absolument
pas. En revanche, ça nous
ça nous cornérise, ça nous marginalise,
ça nous rend impuissant parce qu'on ne
peut plus comprendre le réel. Dès qu'on
est dans le dans la politique, on est
dans l'anathème, on est dans la
dialectique, on est dans ce que font les
gens généralement sur la scène
internationale, l'inverse de ce que
devrait être une vraie diplomatie.
Donc voilà, il faut il faut reprendre
tout ça. Il faut reprendre tout ça.
C'est un vaste programme.
Donc maintenant, on a plus de vraie
diplomatie. On a un qu d'ors Est-ce que
vous pensez que le qu d'ors n'a pas un
peu stérilisé la la pensée stratégique
française ? Est-ce que le Kedorsen n'est
pas peuplé de gens qui sont devenus des
opportunistes dans leur carrière, dans
leur façon d'exercer
caché,
qui n'aiment pas trop prendre des
risques, qui man qui manitiamment le
verbe,
mais dans l'action reste une puissance
de moyenne impuissance.
Alors,
je pense pas qu'il fallait faire des
cops, c'est ça ?
Ouais. Non, mais bien sûr, mais non,
mais je pense pas qu'il faille, c'est
au-delà des personnes, c'est plus grave
que ça
cette autocensure, cette
Oui, c'est plus grave que ça. C'est une
inhibition collective qu'on sentit euh
nié bien souvent ou bien assumé parfois.
Euh mais c'est c'est le système qui ne
va pas. C'est c'est le c'est la pensée
stratégique et diplomatique qui est,
j'allais dire en
ben elle est en train de mourir. Elle
est elle est elle est elle est
moribonde.
Donc il faut la il faut la refonder, il
faut la nourrir de nouveau. Et pour ça,
j'allais dire, je vais employer un terme
un peu, il faut il faut faire une sorte
d'examen de conscience et et et sur ce
qu'on a fait, pourquoi on l'a fait, avec
quel résultat voilà. Or, évidemment,
après, on peut parler des égos, des
intérêts, des opportunités, mais ça, il
y en a partout dans tous les domaines.
C'est voilà. Donc ce qu'il faut, c'est
une direction, c'est une pensée, c'est
une vision. Il y a plus de vision. On en
est aux éléments de langage. Mais c'est
pas ça une diplomatie. Les éléments de
langage, non, il faut une vision. Faut
avoir une faut avoir une idée de ce
qu'on veut faire avec notre pays, de
notre pays et pour notre pays sur la
scène du monde. Après, on en déduit tout
un tas de choses. Je dirais c'est un peu
militaire ce que je veux dire, mais
c'est les lignes d'opération. Mais pour
ça, faut avoir une pensée, faut faut
savoir où on va, faut avoir un effet
final recherché. Il faut euh c'est pour
ça que j'aime le monde militaire
d'ailleurs parce que c'est infiniment
plus cohérent et quand il y a une
incohérence, elle se voit immédiatement
parce que ces conséquences sont
tellement dramatiques que
voilà, on traite de la matière humaine
concrète. Donc donc on est dans une
cohérence nécessaire tandis que l'action
diplomatique et nous avons une
diplomatie de de bon niveau. Nous avons
des grands diplomates, nous en avons.
C'est pas que ça nous manque, c'est
simplement qu'il n'y a plus de
il n'y a plus de boussole. On ne sait
plus où on va en fait. Donc on gère.
Voilà, c'est le c'est le mot de
l'époque, on gère. Mais il s'agit pas de
gérer, il s'agit de vouloir déjà. Il
s'agit de vouloir. Il s'agit de mettre
en ordre de bataille entre guillemets
ses diplomates comme ses services comme
ses armées. Voilà les Enfin,
vous parlez des services.
Oui.
Euh vous connaissez un peu le monde du
renseignement
un petit peu.
À quel niveau ? Intérieur, extérieur ?
Les deux, mon général.
Donc colonel.
Mais c'est vous le général. [grognement]
Je ne suis colonel.
Vous en pensez quoi à l'heure actuelle ?
Ça donne quoi ? Est-ce que le
renseignement brut est mal interprété
par les dendits de salon de salon feutré
ou est-ce que c'est l'appareil d'état
qui n'a pas envie de voir les choses ?
C'est
je pense que là aussi le même travers
s'exprime.
Nous avons d'excellents services de
renseignement.
Le problème c'est une tendance, une
dérive vers la politisation du
renseignement.
Et c'est toujours le même sujet, c'est
la même chose que la diplomatie.
Si vous commencez à politiser au sens au
sens mauvais du terme, hein, pas au sens
noble, au sens
[grognement] réduction,
choix partisan,
confusion entre les interlocuteurs qui
doivent être les nôtres et puis
le le le système intérieur, si vous
voulez. Il y a aussi le problème de la
tyrannie de la transparence, du fait
qu'on doit parler de tout tout le temps.
Bon, moi je suis assez contre ça,
c'est-à-dire que ça on se on se met des
on se lit les mains et les pieds aussi
en faisant ça. Donc il y a tout un tas
de travers, il y a tout un tas de choses
à faire dans la coordination, dans enfin
la réforme du renseignement, elle a été
tentée. Certaines choses ont été menées
et bien menées.
Mais lesquels
il y a eu il y a eu quand même depuis
mon époque euh quel âge vous avez sans
indiscr mais c'est horrible. Ah non non
ah non demande pas ça à une femme de
plus de 25 ans. [rires] Ah non je ne
répondrai pas. Enfin c'est c'est ça peut
se trouver sur le net. Ça se trouve. Bon
mais
euh vous vous avez fait perdre le fil de
ce jeu. Bienvenue chez Sinkerview.
Ouais. [rires]
Ben voilà, voyez, il y a des questions
auxquelles je ne répondrai pas.
Oui. Non, le renseignement euh
déjà en matière de coordination, on a
fait des choses utiles, en matière de
recrutement aussi. Mais par exemple, le
fait que certains pays dans lesquels
nous avons euh une action, en tout cas
une volonté, une présence, une posture,
enfin on peut appeler ça comme on veut,
euh soit des pays dans lesquels nos
services officiellement ou
officiellement ne travaillent pas, ne
doivent pas travailler. Pour moi, c'est
gravissime. S'il y a une chose qui doit
durer, même si on a un pays quasiment en
guerre et cetera, s'il a s'il y a une
permanence, c'est celle des échanges
entre services. C'est fondamental,
c'est structurel, c'est c'est vital.
Bon, donc euh voilà, les appareils de
renseignement, on n'interdit pas à ces
services de travailler, c'est
impossible. Enfin, pour moi, c'est bon,
mais je suis pas je suis pas je suis pas
ministre, hein. Mais euh voilà, pour
moi, ça c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
nous qui nous aveugle. Donc on on se
bouge les oreilles, on ferme les yeux,
on se on se contente de d'un certain
nombre de comme je dis de postures mais
de postures au mauvais sens du terme,
pas des postures militaires, des
postures, [grognement] voilà qui sont
qui sont pauvres, qui sont indigentes et
qui sont totalement inadaptés à la
réalité.
C'est quoi la réalité actuelle ?
Ah alors pour moi, ça c'est un vaste
sujet. La réalité actuelle, bah c'est un
monde qui est en vibration.
C'est un nouveau duopole stratégique
entre la Chine et l'Amérique.
Voilà. Donc ça pour moi c'est le la tête
du nouvel édifice et en dessous il y a
le truc qu'on appelle le
multilatéralisme.
Voilà. Sauf que c'est quand même
globalement bien sûr c'est important. Je
ne dis pas qu'il ne faille pas faire de
multilatéralisme, mais il y a quand même
une renationalisation fondamentale de
tout un tas de puissances
qui qui s'expriment. L'Amérique, elle
n'a jamais cessé, donc c'est pas
nouveau. La Chine maintenant, elle est
dans une phase de de de
maturité [raclement de gorge]
de sa puissance et de déploiement
de revanche sans doute à l'échelle de
l'histoire, mais en tout cas d'une
possibilité inédite et qu'elle va saisir
de se redéployer
pas seulement envers l'Europe, à travers
leur Asie, les routes de la soie et
cetera. Ça ça c'est c'est un problème
dont on va parler mais aussi en Afrique
mais aussi en Asie. Enfin c'est quelque
chose de colossal qui est en train de se
passer. Donc vous avez ça d'un côté là
dragon chinois qui avance. Ça n'est pas
forcément un mal. Encore une fois,
de l'autre côté, vous avez l'Amérique
qui depuis toujours a voulu avoir
l'Europe sous son contrôle
et là toujours l'élargissement a servi à
ça. L'OTAN sert à ça entre autres, mais
sert à ça, sert aussi à vendre des
arbres, mais sert à ça.
Et on voit bien que les divisions
européennes et les les les problèmes
européens qui sont aussi nos problèmes
et nos incapacités. He c'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas l'histoire d'un complot,
c'est l'histoire d'une vision
géopolitique. On a du mal à imaginer
qu'un pays a sa vision géopolitique. Et
nous nous notre truc notre agenda, c'est
la paix. Mais ça veut rien dire. Ça veut
rien dire. Il s'agit pas d'être
offensif, il s'agit d'être construit,
d'être cohérent.
et de peser, c'est un peu comme
Géopragma, de faire masse critique.
Après, on a la Russie qui est diabolisé
à outrance sur ordre ou sur instruction
washingtonienne. Et là, on se pose
absolument pas la question parce on voit
encore la Russie dans les dans des
cercles quand même très importants et
très agissants comme l'Union soviétique
comme si rien n'avait bougé, rien
n'avait changé. On ne comprend pas que
c'est quand même enfin il suffit
pourtant de prendre un planisphère.
C'est la dernière ligne de protection
vis-à-vis pour l'Europe vis-à-vis de la
Chine avant la Chine si j'ose dire. et
on s'est conduit et on continue à se
conduire vis-à-vis de la Russie d'une
façon à mon avis
non seulement assez indigne mais
totalement encore une fois
à contre à contre-temps de nos intérêts
européens. Voilà, ça ne veut pas dire
s'aller, s'aimer d'amour tendre,
s'embrasser sur la bouche parce que eux
aussi ont leur politique
de puissance identifié. Mais simplement
nous on a rien. Nous, on est un espèce
de gros ventre mou et riche. Euh
[gémissement]
il y a des parties qui montent, alors
bon, on les stigmatis comme populiste.
C'est facile. C'est facile. Mais ça ça
c'est c'est juste mettre la poussière
sous le tapis. Il y a il y a tout un tas
de dimensions qui ne sont pas traitées.
Tant qu'elles ne seront pas traitées, ça
fera le jeu des parties comme ça.
Quelles dimensions ne sont pas traitées
?
L'insécurité culturelle, pour moi, c'est
quand même pas un 20 mots. Les
questions, les questions de
souveraineté, de perception de la
souveraineté
des États, c'est-à-dire l'Europe, oui,
mais l'Europe, l'Europe des
souverainetés, la souveraineté
européenne pour moi, ça ne ça ne veut
rien dire. Ça veut strictement rien
dire. Il c'est c'est quand on est fort
et qu'il y a d'autres forts à côté de
soi qu'on peut essayer de faire quelque
chose ensemble. Si c'est juste une bande
de j'allais dire de de d'impuissant qui
se retrouve, qu'est-ce que vous voulez
qu'on fasse ? Donc cette espèce d'idée
plus d'Europe, plus de Oui, bien sûr,
mais plus de quoi ? C'est quoi ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on veut ? Donc on est dans
une espèce de confusion,
les images deviennent le réel.
On ne s'intéresse plus au contenu des
concepts. On ne s'intéresse plus à
l'ampleur de ce qu'il faudrait faire
pour faire bouger certains mécanismes.
D'un point de vue français, on a encore
plein d'autres soucis, notamment
vis-à-vis de l'Allemagne. Enfin, ce qui
vient de se passer il y a il y a
quelques semaines, mais c'est une
vieille histoire. C'est un serpent de
mer. Sauf que là, le serpent, c'est le
monstre du loc qui sort du truc là.
C'est quoi la vieille histoire ? La
vieille histoire, c'est le siège au
conseil de sécurité. Donc là, on est on
est quand même en train
de manière on est en train d'accepter et
je me demande bien pourquoi
pourquoi qu'est-ce qu'on gagne là-dedans
petit à petit ? Alors non, on explique
non, on va pas donner notre siège, on va
avoir un siège européen, il s'agit pas
de mettre l'Allemagne à notre place.
Enfin bref, on est en train de noyer le
truc sur le thème, mais il faut il faut
absolument
euh garder l' il faut rester européen
entre nous, il faut faire quelque chose
entre nous, il faut exister entre nous.
Donc au nom même d'une espèce de
supposée puissance ou influence, on est
en train nous français de
mettre à l'encamp un de nos derniers
attributs de puissance clair et net qui
nous permet encore de faire quelque
chose et surtout d'être un tout petit
peu écouté quand on dit quelque chose.
Après, il faut savoir ce qu'on dit mais
voilà donc je pense qu'on est dans une
on est dans une impasse.
Je pense que beaucoup de gens le savent.
le sent y compris ceux qui ceux qui
réfléchissent et mais personne n'ose
finalement euh dire ce qui ne va pas
clair et net et affirmer des intérêts.
En France, on a beaucoup de mal. On
n'affirme pas. Oui, on parle de on parle
de leadership, on dit "Mais mais
concrètement, notre politique au
Moyen-Orient n'est pas une politique de
leadership." C'est moins qu'on puisse
dire. notre politique vis-à-vis de la
Chine. Oui, c'est bien mais on s'est
déjà fait griller par les Italiens.
Notre politique vis-à-vis de la Russie,
n'en parlons pas.
Vous parlez de griller des Italiens,
vous parlez du fait que la l'Italie va
faire des souscriptions de dette auprès
de la Chine.
Je parle du Oui, mais je je parle du
fait surtout qu'il y a Moi, j'appelle ça
la course à l'échalotte, mais c'est
si vous voulez l'Europe est divisée.
Bon, ça c'est pas nouveau mais
maintenant ça se voit.
Ça se voit notamment depuis 2015. Angela
Merkel a ouvert le la boîte de Pandore
là avec la question migratoire, avec la
la gestion de la question migratoire et
depuis tous ces filoches. Bon et
évidemment tout le monde a intérêt à
diviser l'Europe, sauf peut-être
paradoxalement la Russie. Alors quand je
dis ça, évidemment dire "Mais vous êtes
un agent du Kremelin." Bon d'accord, non
je suis pas un agent du Cremelin. Je
pense que la Russie, elle aurait intérêt
à avoir un bloc européen
plus soudé que simplement jouer les uns
comme les autres, contre les autres. En
revanche, l'Amérique le fait depuis
toujours. Vous avez qu'à voir l'ancien
directeur de campagne là, comment
s'appelle ? Steve Bannon. Euh c'est bon,
lui il a il a monté carrément un
système, une une véritable structure
pour de propagande.
De propagande, Oui, bien sûr. de soutien
à tous les partis euh les plus quand
même les plus extrémistes mais qui
reprennent à leur compte, ils ont pas de
solution mais reprennent à leur compte
des angoisses, des peurs que les bons
européens entre guillemets bons et
notamment les droites européennes
classiques ne traitent plus, ne gèrent
plus, ne veulent plus, n'osent plus
parce que elles aussi elles ont été
stérilisées.
Voilà. Donc euh la droite, la gauche
maintenant euh bon euh donc on est on
est dans une situation difficile. Et de
l'autre côté, la Chine aussi joue les
divisions. Elle joue les Italiens contre
les Français. Elle joue au plus au
francs. Certes, on va faire du gagnant
gagnant et il y a sans doute des choses
très importantes à faire avec les
Chinois. Il faut pas qu'on entre dans
une adversarité bête. Euh mais il faut
pas non plus être complètement naïf.
Moi, je me souviens avoir lu un bouquin,
mais alors c'était il y a déjà sais pas
15 ans, qui s'appelait La Guerreor
Limite
qui était un livre écrit sur commande
naturellement par deux colonels chinois
et qui expliquait. Donc, on était pas du
tout dans la Chine d'aujourd'hui, on
était c'était il y a il y a c'était
après 2001 par là, je crois. euh qui
expliquait clairement que c'était une
une extension de leur impérium, mais
sauf que leur impérium n'est pas du tout
sur le mode américain. Tous azimutes
dans tous les domaines et que c'était
comme ça que ça se menait la guerre et
qu'ils y arriveraient. Voilà. Bon et ben
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on on lit ce
bouquin puis on fait quoi ?
J'ouvre une parenthèse sur la guerre
totale.
C'est quoi le problème avec les flux
migratoires ?
Ben le problème il est
d'abord le problème il est
démographique,
c'est-à-dire qu'effectivement euh les
projections démographiques
et les projections aussi économiques,
même si on dit que l'Afrique est un
Eldorado et cetera et cetera, certes,
mais enfin quand même, il est il est sûr
que nous allons avoir de plus en plus
affaire à des flux migratoires
lourds, constants.
qui [grognement] vont venir
progressivement,
je dirais pas dénaturer mais modifier
modifier la structure
culturelle,
ethnique, linguistique,
religieuse aussi de l'Europe. Bon, alors
là aussi, on a peur de notre ombre. Bah
oui, l'Europe oui, elle est d'origine
chrétienne. Ça ne veut pas dire qu'elle
n'a pas assimilé, qu'elle n'a pas
intégré mais elle le faisait. Là
maintenant on le fait plus, on est dans
le communautarisme.
Donc au nom de l'individu en fait comme
on a par ailleurs désingué avec une
mondialisation assez brutale beaucoup de
d'appartenance tout ça de manière très
idéologique, les gens ils reviennent à
leur communauté. Donc on est en train de
se préparer une peau de léopard, un
truc. Et donc les États face à ça
évidemment euh
euh il devrait être extrêmement fort,
extrêmement sûr d'eux-même, extrêmement
euh euh je dirais pas autoritaire, mais
en tout cas donner des bases, donner des
tout, donner des quotas, dire ce qu'on
veut et comment et à quelles condition.
Et ça n'est pas, il s'agit pas de ne pas
accueillir, il s'agit de pas faire
n'importe quoi. Or, on le fait encore
une fois par les bons sentiments. C'est
le titre de l'interview, mais c'est ça.
Mais les bons sentiments non seulement
vont nous vont nous tuer, mais ne vont
pas pour autant assurer l'équilibre ou
la prospérité des populations
accueillies de cette manière. On le
voit, on le voit chez nous. Bon,
donc on fait quoi ? On laisse la Turquie
faire le sal boulot, on met des camps de
rétention. Libye euh on fait quoi ?
C'est cette peau de léopard, est-ce que
c'est pas une force aussi pour la France
de de d'accueillir cette diversité ?
Est-ce que c'est
Non non non non non. Alors non, [rires]
je fais je vous en prie. Je vous en
prie. Non, non, non. Euh non, la
diversité n'est pas une mauvaise chose
en soi, mais on comprend bien quand même
et il faut vraiment euh faut vraiment
jouer au naïfs pour ne pas comprendre
qu'il y a aussi une question de masse.
Il y a une question de poids relatif des
communautés.
Et quand on a des états qui par ailleurs
sur les aspects égaliens
sont de plus en plus comment dirais-je
indécis ou confus ou ne renforce pas
leurs aspects régaliens
et et le régalien on a abandonné déjà
c'est dire c'est les frontières
c'est les frontières
c'est c'est l'école c'est
voilà c'est c'est un certain nombre de
d'exigences de de devoirs qui vont avec
des droits. Vous allez me dire que je
suis une vieille rétrograde, tout ce
qu'on veut. Enfin, le problème c'est
qu'on est dans une société, il y a il y
a il y a plus que des droits. Il y a
plus que des droits par principe. On a
le droit de piller, on a le droit de
faire c, on a le droit de faire ça. Bah
oui, parce qu'on n'est pas content. Ça
ça marche pas comme ça un état.
On a le droit de piller, c'est-à-dire
Non, mais je pense au aux mouvements
actuels si vous voulez. Je pense
les gilets jaunes ils font pas de
pillage.
Non mais il il laisse quand même il
laisse et de plus en plus parce que même
son noyauté instrumentalisé dévoyé et
cetera et cetera et pénétrer surtout
infiltré. Vous avez déjà été sur un
rond-point
euh oui en voiture pas à pied mais
d'accord vous avez déjà discuté avec les
gilets jaunes ils sont infiltrés par qui
?
Non ça mais ça dans nos campagnes c'est
un autre sujet. Moi je vous parle de
Paris j'habite infiltré par quoi ? Ben,
ils sont infiltrés par tout un tas de
groupuscules qui sont des gens euh je
veux dire euh
quel quel groupes ?
B, des groupuscules de droite, d'extrême
droite, d'extrême gauche, euh des
niilistes, des altères mondialistes
forou furieux, enfin je il faut qu'on
arrête furieux les altères mondialistes.
Bah parce que c'est on peut être altère
mondialiste, mais c'est pas pour ça
qu'on doit détruire
une capitale, je veux dire, ou des ou
des pans d'une capitale ou des rues ou
des avenues, tout n'est [grognement] pas
permis. et et quand par exemple
vo au nom de ces idées,
quand par exemple il y a des hôpitaux
qui ferment, il y a des postes qui
dégagent, il y a des services publics
qui sont détruit,
qui sont pillés d'ailleurs quand on voit
les privatisations de certaines
entreprises,
est-ce que c'est pas plus néfaste mais
moins visible que euh une violence qui
se matérialise dû à une prise de
conscience ?
Oui, mais elle se matérialise
au détriment global si vous voulez.
Alors moi, vous avez bon, c'est vrai que
j'ai une vision j'ai une vision très
régalienne, c'est-à-dire elle se elle se
je ne pense pas qu'on aide quoi que ce
soit, ni la réforme de l'État, ni celle
des hôpitaux, de la santé, de l'école en
faisant ce qu'on fait.
1789, il fallait faire quoi ?
La révolution 1789, on pourrait en
parler, c'est une révolution bourgeoise.
Il y avait trois pelés deux tondus dans
la Bastie. Faut qu'on faut qu'on arrête
aussi là-dessus.
C'est voilà, c'est c'est notre
mythologie, mais il y a eu d'autres
phases dans l'histoire de France tout
aussi,
comment dirais-je constructrice de ce
qu'a été la France parce qu'elle n'est
plus forcément complètement aujourd'hui
parce que justement il s'agit de
structurer un collectif. Il s'agit de ne
pas laisser le pays se
se [grognement] ce se Oui, moi je
j'appelle ça la peau de léopard, mais
c'est un peu ça. C'est un peu ça.
C'est-à-dire petit à petit, on a des
petits des petits groupuscules de
revendication des corporatifs. Il y en a
dans la société, il y en a forcément
mais c'est à ça que doit servir l'État.
Donc si vous voulez quand je parle de de
des pillages, je pense simplement que
force doit rester à la loi quoi.
Il y a pas eu de pillage.
Comment il y a pas eu de pillage ? pas
de piège. Il y a eu quelques
Il y a eu quelques pillag
il y a eu quelques glanages à la fin par
certains.
Ah les glanages ? Ah oui, c'est c'est
joliment dit. Vous êtes allé voir ?
Ouais ouais ouais, pas de problème.
Attendez, vous vous avez vu les
boutiques ? Non mais c'est c'est un truc
de fou. Alors très bien. On dit que
c'est bien, on dit que c'est c'est bon.
Oui, pourquoi pas ? Alors il y a des
gens qui bossent. Bon on s'en fout. On
leur on leur on leur on leur crame leur
deventure, leur kiosque, leur truc. Bon,
qu'est-ce que ça donne à l'étranger, ça
? Les kiosques à mon avis à mon sens ont
été ruinés et ravagés parce que
c'est la presse tenue par une
oligarchie.
Donc c'est c'est eux qui ont été pris
pour cible. Certes, le petit kiosquier
qui a rien demandé à personne, qui fait
son petit travail, qui est qui est qui
est là, qui vend ses petits journaux
qui sont produits par combien de de
d'oligarques de la presse ? 9 10
en France en France quelques-uns.
Quelques-uns. D'accord. une poignée.
Ouais,
donc c'est c'est un dommage collatéral
que le fouquet se fasse ravager
euh c'est un un symbole quand le
président Sarkozy allait se faire
taper la cloche au fouet. Ouais mais
mais je vais vous dire pour moi
ça
je me fais encore l'avocat du diable
hein.
Ça pour moi c'est un peu comme
la Libye ou la Syrie ou d'expliquer
c'est c'est c'est de la personnalisation
c'est du
comment dirais-je ? C'est de la
libération d'énergie négative ou
d'indignation et cetera. Mais à la fin
le résultat c'est quoi ?
Je ne pense pas que les gilets jaunes
qui ont des revendications bien
légitimes pour beaucoup pour beaucoup
quelles sont leurs revendications
des revendications de de pouvoir d'achat
de vie un peu et surtout de sens aussi
de face
de dignité face à la désertification
face au fait effectivement qu'il y a des
déserts
descendant de gens de peu de gens
d'accord je suis bien d'accord mais
monsieur alors là oui je je là vous
prêchez une convaincue je trouve Ça
scandaleux. Voilà. Euh
un ministère se fait enfoncer la porte
par un fenouw, par un transpalette. H
c'est légitime, pas légitime ? C'est une
façon de faire.
Non non, c'est pas une façon de faire.
Non non
parce que l'État n'est pas un ennemi. Et
en France, je trouve ça un peu fort de
café d'expliquer que l'État est
l'ennemi. Si vous voulez, on est quand
même
c'est l'ennemi.
Mais l'ennemi c'est c'est ce sont les
perversions d'un système que l'on laisse
trop faire. Ce sont des disparités trop
grandes. Ce sont euh voilà, mais si vous
voulez, moi je je vous me faites penser
à Hollande qui au président Hollande qui
expliquait qu'on était riche à 4000 €.
Moi, je pense pas qu'on soit riche à
4000 € si vous voulez. C'estàdire le
problème c'est ça, c'est qu'il y a il y
a les disparités se sont tellement
tellement tellement distendues
mais au milieu euh vous avez tout un tas
de gens qui bossent comme des fous et
moi j'en connais plein et qui gagnent
bien leur vie mais ils la volent pas et
ceuxa je vois pas pourquoi on va leur
chercher des noix. C'està-dire on a
aussi des problèmes et des travers
français 1789. Oui, on s'en souvient
encore. C'est-à-dire que on a cette
espèce de revanchisme, espèce de volonté
d'avoir ce qu' a l'autre. On a même
enfin c'est c'est pour moi c'est
ridicule. L'État est un allié.
Vous avez pas une une erreur de
socioperception sur ce conflit là ? Oh
ben on a tous des erreurs de
socioerception en fonction de du monde
dans lequel on vit, de l'éducation qu'on
a reçu, de ce qu'on a vu. Moi, j'essaie
de me placer plus large. Si vous
regardez la France par rapport au reste
du monde, bon,
c'est presque un peu indécent. Voilà. Si
on si on si on lève le si on prend la
longue vue au lieu de prendre la loupe,
on se dit "Attends, c'est bon, on est
dans un on est dans un pays quand même
de cocagne. On est dans un pays de
cocagne. On a envie de temps en temps de
leur dire "Mais allez donc vous balader,
vous vous-même vous le savez, vous avez
voyagé."
Bon, donc euh il y a ça. Deuxièmement,
l'image de la France à l'étranger parce
que notre problème c'est quand même euh
le problème de perception d'une maîtrise
du pouvoir tel qu'il est là aujourd'hui.
Et moi, je suis plutôt une légitimiste,
c'est-à-dire que je peux avoir mes
envies, mes goûts. Bon, mais voilà, il
est là, hein. Donc on va pas on va pas
faire la révolution. On va essayer de
faire en sorte que ça tienne et que nos
institutions résistent et elles sont
bien faites quand même.
Mais vis-à-vis de l'étranger, mais on
passe pour des clownes. On passe pour
des clownes.
Pourquoi ?
Bah parce que les Champs-Élysées détruit
une fois les manifestations interdites
qui se produisent quand même. Je veux
dire c'est c'est pour moi c'est
inadmissible. C'est inadmissible. Et ça
c'est stratégique des gilets jaunes.
Oui, je pense qu'ils auraient dû très
vite vite
se désolidariser ne ne pas
comment dirais
fait pour la plupart hein.
Oui, il y en a plein qui l'ont fait mais
on voit bien qu'il y a quand même
majorité
Oui. Mais il y a quand même une frange
qui se mêle à des gens qui n'ont rien à
voir avec eux et qui du coup
décrédibilise leur revendication. Et
j'aimerais bien savoir ce qui va sortir
de tout ça en terme de législation, de
proposition.
Mon avis c'est pit. Donc euh qu'est-ce
qu'on gagne à la fin ? C'est pas ça le
sujet. Le sujet pour moi, c'est
peut-être de alors il y a des il y a des
vraies grandes réformes à faire, mais il
faut aussi que les gens comprennent
qu'ils doivent travailler beaucoup plus
quand même dans ce pays parce qu'on est
quand même dans un pays où on travaille
très peu hein. Voilà. Donc par rapport
aux autres, par rapport aux autres,
c'est toujours la même chose. Si on
était tous à l'île moustique, ça irait
bien, mais on n'est pas tous à l'île
moustique.
Donc juste à côté de l'île moustique
Morpion.
Est-ce que [rires] Est-ce que vous
connaissez les Morpions de l'évasion
fiscale ?
Alors non, mais vous allez me dire
l'évasion fiscale représente quel volume
d'argent pour la France ?
Bah quelques milliards,
petites centaines quand même, non ?
Petite centaines de milliards.
On dit 130 Ouais mais ouais mais je n'en
sais rien. Je n'en sais rien. Mais
l'évasion fiscale c'est vieux comme
l'homme hein. Ça va pas disparaître
hein.
Ça a pris quand même des proportions
dingues en ce moment non ? Ouais mais
c'est un problème d'Europe. On n pas
d'harmonie fiscale et nous on est
c'estàdire c'est aussi c'est les
incohérences européennes. Lichttenstein,
il y a le Luxembourg puis il y a la
Suisse pas loin non plus qui y est sans
en être. Enfin bref donc on a fait quand
même beaucoup de progrès. Mais l'évasion
fiscale
c'est pas pour moi c'est pas le sujet.
Pour moi, c'est pas le sujet. Pour moi,
il faut détabouiser l'argent dans ce
pays et ça c'est un problème culturel
lourd parce qu'on est une culture
catholique.
Combien vous gagnez ?
Oh bah alors si je vous disais
il faut détabouiser
rien. Je gagne rien. Je gagne rien.
Comment vous faites pour vivre ?
Non je je vais peut-être pas rentrer
dans l'intimité de ma vie mais je je ne
je ne gagne rien franchement. Moi, je
fais du jusqu'à présent j'ai fait
énormément de bénévolat et de
philanthropie stratégique depuis que je
me suis arrêté de travailler quasiment
euh donc depuis 2002. Voilà. Donc il
m'arrive de faire un peu de conseil, de
donner quelques conférences et cetera.
Il faut que je développe d'ailleurs
beaucoup tout ça. Et d'ailleurs
c'est pas au RSA.
Non non mais non, je même jamais touché
le chômage alors que j'avais droit à 2
ans et demi de chômage après avoir
quitté les services de l'État. J'ai
considéré que c'était pas légitime, même
si j'avais cotisé pendant 10 ans. Euh
j'ai considéré que
j'en avais pas besoin. Donc voilà.
[grognement] Donc non, je là sur
l'argent, voilà, c'est un sujet
difficile, douloureux.
Appel aux bonnes âmes. Je Alors, appel
aux bonnes âmes, attention, c'est-à-dire
je donne des conférences pour des
entreprise, ça m'arrive. [grognement]
Euh mais évidemment, il est très
difficile
d'être payé pour sa liberté de penser.
Voilà. Et moi, une de mes préoccupations
fondamentales, et alors là, on peut me
proposer des ponts d'or, c'est que je ne
suis pas mercenaire.
Voilà, c'est normal, je suis colonel.
Je connais des colonels qui ont finit
mercenaires, mais bon.
Revenons à nos moutons. La géopolitique.
Ouais.
L'Europe de la défense.
C'est du wishful singing.
C'est une façon de brasser du vent et de
sculter de l'air chaud. C'est quelque
chose qui est nécessaire. Qu'est-ce que
c'est ?
C'est absolument nécessaire. Mais ce qui
est nécessaire, c'est la défense de
l'Europe.
Voilà ce qui est un peu différent parce
que pour l'instant,
quelles sont les menaces ? Quels sont
les risque ?
Bah les risques
d'abord c'est la alors c'est pas la
défense de l'Europe pour aller faire la
guerre. Évidemment, la défense de
l'Europe, c'est la démonstration
d'une en fait déjà d'une cohérence et
d'une cohésion dans la pensée
stratégique dans la manière dont
l'Europe se projette. comme un ensemble
comme je vous l'ai dit entre la Chine et
l'Amérique avec un certain nombre avec
la Russie à côté avec un certain nombre
de menaces de toute nature.
Donc c'est ça qu'il faut qui c'est ça la
bonne échelle. Bon, pour faire ça,
évidemment, ça devient très compliqué
quand on voit ce qui arrive à Airbus
parce qu'évidemment les nations ont
chacune leurs intérêts industriels,
leurs intérêts commerciaux, leurs
intérêts
d'exportation d'armement, leurs
intérêts, voilà de toute nature.
et et donc certaines sont déjà plus
indépendantes que d'autres en matière de
réflexion, en matière de d'évaluation de
leurs propres intérêts. Tout part de là
si vous n'évaluez pas vos propres
intérêts, vous êtes mal barré. Quant à
l'OTAN, bon ben on voit maintenant l'un
des mérites du président Trump, c'est
que il explique d'une façon tellement
tellement limpide et tellement sans
équivoque la façon dont l'Amérique nous
a toujours considéré. C'est pas nouveau
ce qu'il dit. Ce qui est nouveau c'est
la manière. La manière, elle est cache.
Voilà, elle est comme il est quoi. Elle
est cache. C'est-à-dire l'Europe, elle
obéit, hein. Elle obéit. à ce moment-là,
on veut bien la protéger, on veut bien
s'en occuper et encore à voir dans quel
cadre et cetera. Elle achète des armes
américaines, c'est évident parce que
toute l'histoire qu'il y a eu alors je
sais même plus c'était avant l'été euh
sur les 2 % de budget que chaque pays
européen devrait euh consacrer. Bon, en
fait concrètement, ça veut dire acheter
des armes américaines. C'est pas une
question d'indépendance. Ça n'a rien à
voir. Ça n'a rien à voir avec la
responsabilité. C'est juste bon
maintenant ça va être plus cher.
C'est l'effort de guerre américain.
C'est ça.
Bah l'Amérique est construite là-dessus.
L'Amérique elle est construite sur un
système militarauindustriel. L'Amérique
elle a
elle a besoin pour se justifier d'abord
dans ce qu'elle considère comme sa
destinée manifeste et sa nation
indispensable, n'est-ce pas ? Son statut
de nation indispensable au monde. Elle a
besoin évidemment
de clientèle. Bon, comme d'autres, mais
elle a besoin de
bah finalement de pouvoir expliquer
qu'elle apporte la paix. Pour apporter
la paix, bah il y a deux solutions. Soy
il y a des vraies guerres et on fait
quelque chose de bien, soit on crée des
guerres, on déstabilise la planète.
Quand on voit le Moyen-Orient quand
même, c'est assez c'est assez net. Là,
elle est en train de reprendre en main
l'Amérique latine, clairement, Brésil,
le Venezuela. Alors avec des succès
divers parce que je crois qu'aux
dernières nouvelles, Juan Gooido est
quasiment aux arrêts ou pas loin.
[grognement] Donc on est voilà, il y a
une il y a une reprise en main. La
doctrine Monro est en train de redevenir
tout à fait opérationnelle et puis pour
le reste sa politique c'est le
containment. Donc contenir la Russie,
contenir l'Europe, empêcher une
véritable alliance euh
russoau-allemande. Ça c'est leur
angoisse numéro 1 depuis toujours. C'est
une angoisse géopolitique de fond. Euh
c'est pour ça, c'est aussi pour ça euh
que la question de récemment euh
revivifié
là de Nordstream 2 euh s'est posé. Euh
donc il y a toute une guerre
énergétique. Il y a maintenant une
Amérique qui est première exportateur
mondiale de pétrole.
Donc quand on voit les questions du Vené
qui a les premières réserves prouvées,
on comprend on comprend un peu plus ce
qui est en train de se passer tout de
même. Donc l'Amérique, elle a en ligne
de mire la Chine comme concurrent mais
aussi comme partenaire, d'où la guerre
commerciale pour installer un bon
rapport de force. Et moi, je trouve que
Trump n'agit pas si mal de ce point de
vue-là. Si on se met à sa place, encore
une fois, parce que un géopolitologue
théoriquement c'est ça, il doit se
mettre à la place de chacun des acteurs
pour essayer de comprendre quelque
chose. S'il se met à faire de la morale,
des principes et à dire "Celui-là, je
l'aime, celui-là je l'aime pas". Alors
là, on est c'est autre chose. C'est
Madame Soleil, c'est c'est c'est les
bisous nours, mais c'est plus de la
géopolitique. Donc du point [grognement]
de vue de Trump,
la Chine est la cible et en même temps
c'est le pire compétiteur. Donc c'est
vraiment le le la personne avec laquelle
on parle de tout et de tous les autres.
Voilà. [grognement] Et donc le marché
chinois de l'énergie, bah il est il est
juste colossal. Donc on comprend tout.
On comprend beaucoup de choses vis-à-vis
de la Russie, vis-à-vis de l'Iran,
vis-à-vis du Venezuela, donc vis-à-vis
même du Qatar. Enfin, on on comprend
beaucoup de on comprend que en
géopolitique,
la carte énergétique des conflits est
une des grilles de lecture majeur qu'on
ne voit pas forcément toujours. C'est
pour ça qu'on moralise les
affrontements, c'est pour ça qu'on
diabolise les individus, c'est pour ça
qu'on personnalise les conflits, on se
bat contre machin après lui avoir serré
la la main pendant des décennies.
La Libye, c'était quoi ? une grosse
erreur.
Mais ça tout le monde le sait
maintenant. [rires]
Ah je sais pas moi [soupir][grognement]
je suis pas sûr que tout le monde le
sache. Non si vous écoutez certains
indicent oui. J'allais le dire j'allais
le dire si vous l'écoutez. Non lui il
pense que c'était vraiment très
important et cetera.
La démocratie pour les petites filles.
Oui les petites filles. Les petites Non
mais le problème c'est que c'est pas ça
le sujet. On apportera la démocratie à
personne. Voilà parce que
on a déjà jamais apporté. C'est ça.
Ben, je me demande, je sais pas,
peut-être oui, il y a peut-être des
contrexemples ou des exemples qui
confirment la règle, mais au Moyen
Orient, je demande à voir, c'est que
qu'on me cite de véritable démocratie en
Afrique.
C'est c'est pas sérieux tout ça. Donc
c'est pour ça que la morale ne
la morale n'est la morale est un masque.
La morale est une c'est une imposture.
La posture morale est une imposture.
Voilà, c'est clair. et le et le et le
moralisme et le l'idéalisme moralisateur
est vraiment pour moi le comble du cyme.
Voilà. Parce que bon, moi je me prétends
réaliste et ce que je veux installer,
c'est un pôle un peu néoréaliste
en géopolitique, évidemment, on dira les
réalistes sont des cyniques. Mais c'est
exactement l'inverse. Le procès en
cynisme fait au réalistes,
c'est vraiment un procès, c'est un
procès de Moscou quoi. C'est un truc
c'est la Libye fait pourquoi ?
Je n'en sais rien. Très honnêtement, je
n'en sais rien. Mais le résultat le
résultat est dramatique. Vous avez voté
Nicolas SarkoZi ?
Euh oui, j'ai voté Nicolas SarkoZier.
Ouais, mais pas euh enfin j'ai voté
Nicolas Sarkozier en 2007.
H
Vous êtes content de son intervention en
Libye ?
Non, non, non. Ah mais non, non. Et ni
de la réintégration dans le temps, dans
le commandement militaire. Ah non, ben
non, mais moi j'ai été déçu au plan
international. très très enfin Hollande
c'était encore voilà donc moi de toute
façon c'est une erreur
ah ben colossale
est-ce que c'est regarder le pays
et il y a qu'à regarder les conséquences
euh
migratoires de déstabilisation
régionale
de de hub pour des terroristes de enfin
je veux dire c'est n'importe quoi quoi.
les milices islamistes, les Mrata, un
gouvernement fantoche qui ne représente
que lui-même, qui est complètement sous
la coupe des islamistes. De l'autre
côté, un général qui est en train
d'essayer de reprendre les choses un peu
en main à sa manière, mais enfin qui
quand même a une représentativité bien
plus grande mais que naturellement on ne
reconnaît pas parce qu'on s'est on s'est
pris les pieds dans le tapis, on s'est
encore une fois, on a fait le mauvais
choix, hein. Donc maintenant, pour ne
pas perdre la face, on s'enfonce, on
s'enfonce au lieu au lieu d'être
pragmatique.
Qu'est-ce qu'on veut ? Est-ce qu'on veut
vraiment que les libiens s'en sortent ?
Est-ce que le peuple libien nous importe
? Si le peuple libien nous importe, il
faut vraiment d'urgence revenir à une
politique beaucoup plus réaliste. Il
faut prendre celui qui est capable
d'apporter la stabilité, celui qui est
capable de contrôler les milices
islamistes. Et oui, c'est ça qu'il soit
grand démocrate, petit démocrate,
autocrate,
c'est franchement c'est c'est pas c'est
pas sérieux. On parle de masse
importante, on parle de de de de
déstabil la la libe de Kaddafi. Bon
alors Kaddafi c'était Kaddafi bien c'est
pas je suis pas je n'ai pas de je suis
pro rien moi. Donc de toute façon, c'est
niant euh Kaddafi c'était Kaddafi, mais
enfin sous Kaddafi, il y avait quand
même une modernité sociale à partir du
moment où ils ont du pétrole
très importante, tout à fait même
inédite dans la région je dirais en
matière d'enseignement, en matière
d'hôpitaux, en matière de de
d'université, enfin en matière de
liberté des femmes. Mais là pour le
coup, c'était un pays bon qui c'est un
pays qui vivait de rente. Très bien,
mais euh les Libyens n'étaient pas dans
l'état dans lequel ils sont, comme les
iraquiens d'ailleurs, comme les Syriens
d'ailleurs.
Pourquoi on a desingué Kaddafi ?
Mais je n'en sais rien. Moi je je
n'étais pas dans le bureau du président,
hein.
Vous avez bien une petite idée quand
même ?
Non, si vous voulez me faire dire mais
je je n'ai pas d'éléments. Moi, j'aime
pas parler de ce que je ne connais pas.
Vous connaissez Fabrice Arpie ? Euh pas
personnellement, mais oui, je l'ai
peut-être vu sur euh
Est-ce que vous avez suivi euh ces
enquêtes sur euh
Oui, j'ai lu. Oui, oui, oui, oui. Non,
mais bien sûr.
Ça ça vous paraît réaliste ?
Ça me paraît euh
possible.
Possible mais je n'en sais rien moi.
Vous savez, je plus ça va, plus je suis
comme Saint-Thomas.
Oui.
Ouais. [soupir]
J'aime bien, j'aime bien, j'aime bien
l'entendre de la bouche du cheval, quoi.
Ouais. Ben là, ça va être compliqué de
l'entend.
Ça va être compliqué.
La Syrie, c'est quoi ? C'est un beau
pays ? C'est une erreur ? C'est c'est
quoi ? C'est un drame la série. Moi, je
crois à la souveraineté des États. Je
remarque
que l'Irak, la Syrie, la Libye
sont les trois pays qui étaient
puissants, riches,
laïques,
qui protégeaient
la pluralité confessionnelle ethnique.
Je parle pas du je parle pas de la
démocratie comme chez nous évidemment
mais il y en a pas. C'est c'est pas
possible. Ça marche pas comme ça. Ça
marche par clan, ça marche par
confession, ça marche par c'est c'est ça
ça n'a c'est ça n'est pas valable. On
peut toujours comme ça en France aussi
non ? Il y a les clans politiques, les
clans financiers. Mais
de plus en plus mais de plus en plus.
Mais là on parle
Ouais mais bon justement moi j'aimerais
qu'on revienne à des à des principes un
peu plus sain. Donc
alors pour revenir à la Syrie,
on est on avait commencé sur la Syrie.
C'est très important la Syrie.
Je pense que là aussi,
il y a eu sans doute au départ une
révolte plus ou moins contrôlée, plus ou
moins stimulé comme la plupart des
révoltes, hein.
Moi, je je j'ai un peu de mal avec les
mouvements spontanés. Bon, il y en a
sans doute.
Révolution orange, révolution de Jasme.
Ah non, Révolution orange, non, ça
voilà.
Euh mais donc il y a eu une phase
initiale mais qui a duré très peu de
temps, qui a duré quelques mois euh
populaire.
Le problème c'est que l'opposition
syrienne politique politique euh
j'allais dire comment dirais-je du pays
enfin autochtone euh
n'existe pas.
Alors, on va dire et pour cause bon très
bien. Donc, on est allé chercher des
gens partout à Londres, à Paris,
partout, des exilés qui avait des
ambitions, hein. On a essayé de créer
une alternative qui n'en était
absolument pas une, qui n'avait qui
avait une représentativité zéro. Et
pendant ce temps, le monde entier a
envoyé ses djihadistes. Voilà. Donc
après, c'est une très longue histoire,
le pays et l'État et l'armée ont résisté
jusqu'à un point où ça devenait trop
difficile parce que le rapport de force
devenait trop difficile, trop compliqué.
Les puissances occidentales comme
d'habitude ont cherché à favoriser
en fait des groupuscules. Enfin, on se
souvient d'Alnostnos fait du bon boulot.
Bon très bien. On est on est quand même
sûr de ça que Laurent Fabius a prononcé
cette phrase là.
Oui, il l'a dit.
Oui.
C'est quoi votre source ?
Ma source
c'est pas la bouche du cheval. [rires]
C'est pas la bouche du cheval. Mais bien
sûr, il l'a dit. Mais d'ailleurs, il ne
le ni pas. Il l'a pas nié. Donc
mais c'est un vrai problème. Al Nostra,
c'est Al-Qaïda. Al-Qaïa, c'est 2001
de manière très visible.
Donc on est dans une schizophrénie
totale. C'est-à-dire pour moi et c'est
le problème de notre politique étrangère
au Levant, nous favorisons
pour des raisons qui m'échappent
et qui à mon avis ne sont pas que
financières ou économiques, c'est il
s'agit pas seulement de marché
d'armement. Nous favorisons
des mouvements et des et des
proxies de puissance sunite
qui sont en fait la source d'inspiration
chez nous de la déstabilisation
sécuritaire et terroriste.
Donc il y a quand même un moment où il
faudrait faire le lien quoi entre
l'intérieur et l'extérieur. Ça s'appelle
le continuum défense sécurité.
Voilà, c'est pas un 20 mots pour moi.
Donc c'est très grave. Pour moi, c'est
très très grave. Et on se met maintenant
enfin on ne comprend rien. On ne
comprend rien.
On va prendre deux trois questions
internet
moutons.
On va vous faire souffler un peu avec
des questions gentilles.
Oui.
Comment les néocons ont infiltré
l'appareil militaire français ?
Militaire.
Est-ce qu'ils ont infiltré l'appareil
militaire français ?
Euh
déjà, je suis pas sûr de pouvoir dire
que les néocons ont infiltré l'appareil
militaire. Une
question internet posée de Brutamb.
Ouais. Euh non, les mouvements
néoconservateurs et atlantistes ont
infiltré la haute administration
française, ça c'est clair. Les milieu
intellectuel, c'est clair.
Le milieu militaire, non, parce que en
France, l'armée qui malheureusement de
plus en plus se considère simplement
comme un outil militaire, ce qui est
aussi révélateur d'une évolution que moi
je trouve déplorable
comme une femme de ménage.
Non, mais la spécificité du métier
militaire est en train progressivement
de disparaître par le biais de d'un
certain nombre de dérives notamment de
la civilisianisation du ministère de la
défense. Enfin, il y a beaucoup de
choses si vous voulez, mais ça aussi ça
date des années 2000, 2005 du nouveau
statut militaire et progressivement
les armées finalement, même si elles
sont toujours aussi remarquables,
toujours aussi héroïques, toujours aussi
courageuses, si elles font toujours des
miracles avec des bouts de chandelle
[grognement] en dépit de ce qu'on nous
raconte,
et bien elles sont réduites à voilà à
faire ce que le politique
ménage quoi.
Non non, c'est non non, vous me ferez
pas vous me ferez pas dire que les
armées françaises sont une femme de
ménage. Non. Bah
l'armée française est devenue quand même
l'organe qui va réparer les erreurs
politiques. Non,
pas forcément réparer
les amplifier
parfois. Oui, parfois. Mais mais c'est
un vrai problème. Bien sûr. Je je mais
c'est pas c'est pas on n'est pas une
femme de ménage. On obéit aux
politiques. On obéit aux politiques.
Donc quand le politique est mal inspiré,
mal conseillé, mal orienté, buté
et ne veut ne veut pas décider et
préfère obéir lui-même.
Obéir à qui ?
Bah obéir à ce qu'on peut lui conseiller
aimablement du côté du grand frère.
Voilà. Euh et bien ça donne ça. Donc nos
armées après qu'est-ce que vous voulez ?
Elles obéissent.
Un ordre donné doit être doit être
exécuté sans être discuté. C'est ça
a priori
autre question d'internet. La
démographie européenne est en déclin. La
population est vieillissante et ne et ne
se renouvelle plus. Ne pensez-vous pas
qu'on va laisser mourir l'Europe en
refusant l'immigration ?
Ouais. Alors ça c'est le problème c'est
que c'est pas les vases communiquants
les nations. C'est pas parce qu'il y a
rien dans un dans un tube qu' suffit de
mettre le contenu d'un autre tube pour
que ça refasse un petit un petit liquide
et un bon niveau. On peut faire ça mais
c'est plus c'est plus le même contenu
quoi. Donc il faut il faut pour moi
recréer une structuration. Il faut moi
je suis contre l'horizontalité si vous
voulez. Pour moi, l'horizontalité ça
nous tue. Voilà, je crois à la
verticalité, la verticalité de la
réflexion déjà et la verticalité de la
direction et du et du management comme
on dit en tout cas du du commandement
des hommes, des choses, des
administrations. Et donc, je pense que
le problème, il est à la tête.
Efficace, c'est efficace.
Ah bah quand c'est quand il y a
quelqu'un à la tête qui Oui.
Général de Gaulle, par exemple. un
général de Gaulle sans doute. Oui, sans
aucun doute. Oui, sans aucun doute. On
on voit pas beaucoup émerger des des
problème. C'est qu'il y a une espèce en
voie de disparition qui s'appelle
l'homme d'État.
Voilà, nous sommes dans un pays où il y
a il y a il y a pas que les les
[grognement] les grèbes à tête upé ou
les fous de bass qui disparaissent. Il y
a aussi les hommes d'état. Voilà. Donc
c'est vrai, c'est vrai. Un homme d'état,
un homme d'état
ou une femme d'ailleurs, enfin un être
d'état quoi. Un être qui croit à l'État.
Vous voyez qui par exemple ?
Et qui est capable de d'endurer
d'endurer l'impopularité.
Macron, c'est un bon président pour
vous.
Euh
comme je l'ai dit, j'étais légitimiste.
C'est-à-dire que
une fois qu'il a été élu, j'ai considéré
qu'il fallait
l'aider ou en tout cas espérer qu'il
réussisse.
J'ai trouvé ses premiers pas en
politique étrangère très bons.
Euh
j'ai même eu l'outre cuidance de donner
de d'écrire deux petites chroniques dans
le point qui s'appelait petit manuel de
diplomatie à l'usage de de du président
ou quelque chose comme ça. Puis après,
je me suis arrêtée, je me suis Bon
[grognement]
euh malheureusement
euh
il y a les entourages, il y a les
pesanteurs, il y a l'inertie, il y a la
mauvaise perception de ce qu'on doit
faire, il y a le refus de se remettre en
cause, il y a le problème de de ne pas
vouloir avouer aussi les erreurs qu'on a
faites. C'est rien de pire ça. C'est
dire, non seulement vous faites une
annie, mais vous la poursuivez 10 ans.
Ah chouette !
Avec votre argent ?
Oui, avec notre argent accessoirement.
Oui. Oui. Mais mais en tant que tel, si
vous voulez, si on se place du point de
vue de l'intérêt national, moi c'est
quand même ma préoccupation. C'est ça le
problème, c'est que moi je ne je pense
que il est beaucoup plus important de
dire parfois qu'on s'est trompé, de
repartir sur une autre base que de
s'enferrer Advitam et Ternam dans les
mêmes erreurs. La Syrie est un excellent
exemple.
C'est bon, la guerre est gagnée, elle a
été gagnée. Nous nous sommes trompés.
Nous nous sommes trompés de Paris, nous
nous sommes trompés d'Aliés. Nous nous
sommes trompés d'à peu près tout.
Euh, il va falloir reconstruire ce pays.
Il va falloir qu'il se reconsolide
politiquement. Il va falloir que le
pouvoir s'ouvre. Il va falloir une
nouvelle constitution. Il va falloir
plein de choses. Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Faut qu'on arrête juste de dire Bachard
est l'ennemi de son peuple et il faut
c'est pas le sujet en fait. C'est bien
plus compliqué que ça. C'est bien plus
important que ça. Bachar voilà, il a
fait ce qu'il pouvait. Il est lui-même
sous contrôle quand même très largement
et sous des contrôles qui ne sont pas
forcément convergents contrairement à ce
qu'on veut faire croire.
Contrôlé par qui ? Bacharad.
Non mais entre l'Iran et la Russie si
vous voulez il a deux il a deux
puissances quand même qui appuient
sérieusement. Qui t'a fait roi ? Enfin
qui t'a maintenu roi plus
je vais je vais essayer de vous faire
écouter quelque chose. C'était pas prévu
mais euh on va essayer de de l'écouter
ensemble. Ouais,
je vais rapprocher mon micro de du
haut-parleur pour que les internautes
puissent s'écouter avec nous.
D'accord.
Des chefs de guerre, il y en a toutes
sortes. Des bons, des mauvais, des
pleines cagettes, il y en a. Mais une
fois de temps en temps, il en sort un
exceptionnel,
un héros, une légende, des chefs comme
ça, il aura presque jamais. Mais tu sais
ce qu'ils ont tous en commun ? Tu sais
ce que c'est leur pouvoir secret ?
Non. Ils ne se battent que pour la
dignité des faibles.
Est-ce que vous trouvez que Emmanuel
Macron se bat pour la dignité des
faibles ?
Déjà, je suis pas d'accord.
Pourquoi ?
Un chef d'état ne se bat pas forcément
pour la dignité des faibles.
Ah bon ? Pourquoi ?
Non, mais il se bat pour la la dignité
de son état.
et dans son état, il n'y a pas que des
faibles. Donc c'est déjà une vision très
idéologique des choses de mon point de
vue.
Euh
je voudrais pas trop me mettre à à
parler de politique parce que vous savez
vraiment c'est pas mon sujet en fait.
Alors on va parler de géopolitique.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez du forum avec
Sijing Ping
Angela Merkel et du discours de Sijing
Ping ? Vous l'avez forcément vu ? Oui.
Non, je l'ai pas vu d'ailleurs. Non, je
l'ai pas vu. [grognement]
Alors le forum avec Junker et et Merkel
c'est une
je trouve moi que ça n'est pas une
mauvaise idée, c'est-à-dire d'avoir
voulu montrer ou manifester incarner de
manière concrète quoi [grognement]
le fait que
il ne sera pas forcément possible
toujours à la Chine de jouer les
Européens les uns contre les autres.
Après, qu'est-ce que ça recouvre
véritablement ? C'est tout le problème
de la politique aujourd'hui. C'est que
l'image a pris la place du réel. On
n'est plus que dans des
postures, des accolades, des c, des ça,
des grandes déclarations. Mais
pour moi euh c'est pas ça l'essentiel.
L'essentiel c'est d'envoyer ses hommes,
d'envoyer ses grands diplomates,
d'envoyer les gens qui en a confiance.
parler à ceux auquels théoriquement il
ne faut pas parler. C'est c'est ça une
vraie politique étrangère digne de ce
nom. C'est pas de parler à ses potes,
hein.
Est-ce qu'il y a Est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il y a une nouvelle forme de
macartisme dans la dans la géopolitique
et dans la perception de de la
géopolitique ? Est-ce que vous pensez
pas qu'il y a une bienpensance
à à tous les niveaux ? Qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire pour changer ça ?
Ben, il faut faire ce que je vais faire.
Si si je ne jeais dire si je ne passe
pas sous un camion, mais c'est pour
rigoler. Mais euh
ou pas
ou pas ou [grognement] pas quoi ?
Tant que vous êtes petite, personne vous
emmerdera.
Oui, mais je Oui, mais comme je vous
l'ai dit, je pense qu'il faut faire
masse. Il faut montrer il faut montrer
la masse que l'on représente de fait. Et
c'est une masse de bon sens. C'est pas
une masse délirante, c'est une masse de
bon sens d'un certain nombre de gens
forts, calés, intelligents, pénétr
l'idée du bien de leur pays
et de dans toutes ces composantes et qui
doivent pouvoir proposer des solutions
alternatives, analyser les choses
différemment, montrer une autre voie,
une autre définition de l'intérêt de
l'État.
Donc oui, on est dans une bienpensance
totale, on est dans une chambre d'éco,
c'est-à-dire c'est formidable, on est
dans une bulle, tout le monde se répond,
tout le monde se répète, c'est c'est
narcisse quoi. On est on est on est on
est là. Bon et c'est un peu le problème
de des structures
dites de réflexion stratégique. On va
vous demander une piste pour solutionner
le problème du terrorisme. Qu'est-ce
qu'on fait pour solutionner le
terrorisme ?
Non mais je ne suis pas euh je suis pas
euh je suis pas Dieu. Pour solutionner
le terrorisme déjà Dieu,
je crois en quelque chose. Ouais.
Vous avez un ami imaginaire ?
[rires]
Euh non, je crois je crois en un
principe. Oui, je crois
un gros architecte.
Non non non, je crois en quelque chose
qui nous échappe. Je crois qu'on n'est
pas l'alpha et l'oméga nous les hommes.
Ouais. Voilà.
Après la foi c'est encore autre chose
pour moi,
mais déjà le doute c'est important
le doute m'habite.
Donc euh [grognement]
le terrorisme et ben déjà il faut il
faut être cohérent. La cohérence c'est
le maître mot, il faut être cohérent.
Donc, on ne peut pas de fait appuyer peu
ou prou euh des groupuscules, des
tendances, des mouvan, des idéologies
qui prôent euh la la destruction en fait
des communautés euh euh classiques,
occidentales,
construites, culturelles, chrétienne en
l'espèce
et espérer pouvoir neutraliser ou
assécher le terreau
islamiste qui est dans notre pays, qui
est clair et net maintenant dans notre
pays, qui est totalement installé
maintenant donc et pas que dans notre
pays d'ailleurs. Voilà. Après, il y a
tout un tas d'aspects sociaux mais c'est
pas c'est pas une question d'argentin,
c'est une question d'autorité aussi là.
Voilà, il y a une question d'impunité,
une question de a multiples enjeux. Ce
serait une politique vraiment globale
porte sur la justice, ça porte sur tout,
sur la défense, sur la sécurité, sur
l'école. Sur la justice, on fait quoi ?
Bah sur la justice déjà, on applique nos
lois.
L'état d'urgence, c'est c'est bien,
c'est pas bien,
ça peut l'être. Bah s'il le faut, ça
peut l'être. Pourquoi pas ?
Que ça passe dans la Constitution, c'est
bien.
[grognement]
On peut normalement le le déclarer. Je
veux dire, on a on a le pouvoir
de le mettre en place si c'est
nécessaire. Ce qu'il faut, c'est ce qui
compte c'est la perception de la
réalité. Problème c'est qu'on se rend
bien compte là, ne serait-ce que dans la
gestion de cette crise là des gilets
jaunes et la manière dont elle a été
petit à petit noyautée, on n pas tout
compris quoi. On n pas tout compris. On
laisse faire des choses qu'on devrait
absolument pas laisser faire. Alors
après, on change la posture, maintenant
il faut la tenir parce que c'est toutes
les 3 semaines cette histoire. Donc
voilà, si c'est pour que ça recommence
dans 15 jours, je sais c'est pas
possible. C'est c'est tellement mauvais
et c'est tellement mauvais aussi pour
ceux qui nous ciblent parce que la
France est une cible. Voilà. Donc moins
elle exprime son autorité et je sais
bien que l'autorité n'est plus à n'est
plus à la mode. Euh mais enfin moins
elle exprime son autorité plus on
comprend qu'on peut s'y attaquer.
La solution politique pour les gilets
jaunes. Vous envoyez une
politique ?
Le problème c'est que les gilets jaunes,
ils ont aussi des revendications
totalement contradictoires.
C'est la liste de Noël.
Bah un peu, je veux dire, on peut pas
gagner plus. Non, mais la dessence, la
dignité, ça c'est l'essentiel.
Voilà, ça ça c'est pas c'est évident ça.
C'est légitime à mort. En revanche,
qu'est-ce que la dessence ? Qu'est-ce
que la dignité ? Déjà c'est c'est parce
que là aussi les mots bon c'est
vous voyez une personne de 74 ans se
faire bousculer avoir multiples
fractures. Quand vous voyez des gamins
se prendre des des coups de gomcoin de
flashball pleine tête euh ça vous a
c'est quoi c'est l'ordre qui se
matérialise ? C'est c'est quoi ? Euh je
dirais même pas que c'est l'ordre qui se
matérialise parce que malheureusement
nos forces
en puissance qui se matérialise,
ben c'est-à-dire que si on était enfin
bon, je suis pas policier et je ne suis
pas spécialiste du maintien de l'ordre
mais clairement pour moi, il y a eu un
problème euh de consigne, c'est-à-dire
là aussi c'est une question de posture
mais là c'est les vraies postures. Donc
la posture défensive, la posture de dite
de maintien de l'ordre mais c'est même
pas celle qu'on avait. Je parle même pas
du rétablissement. C'est c'est comme en
Bosnie ça. Vous voyez, c'est quand vous
avez des règles d'engagement qui font
que vous ne pouvez rien faire en fait,
sauf vous tirer, vous enfuir pour ne pas
vous faire lycher et que vous êtes
policier, motard, enfin c'est pas
possible. C'est pas possible. Quant à
cette dame, ben je suis bien malheureuse
pour elle. Euh mais je pense que à 74
ans, effectivement euh quand on a
compris qu'après ce qui s'est passé la
semaine précédente, il y allait y avoir
un dispositif plus euh
voilà plus ferme,
ben on prend des sacrés risques. Voilà.
On prend
C'est ça être français.
Comment
c'est ça ? Français, prendre des risques
?
Oui, mais je suis pas sûre qu'elle prend
des risques pour être française si vous
voulez. C'est
Oui, prendre des risques en soi, c'est
important mais là pour moi, c'est
du c'est ça sert à rien tout ça. Pour
moi, ça sert à rien. Voilà. Ça ne veut
pas dire que le pouvoir fait tout bien.
Ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faut pas
changer les lois. Ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il faut pas faire des réformes, mais
je pense pas que ce soit en en mettant
la pagaille dans le pays que qu'on
avancera quoi que ce soit.
Vous voyez la France comment dans les 3
5 10 15 prochaines années à vous de
choisir l'échelle ?
Courage.
Ouais. Ouais. Vous me posez des des
questions, il faut faire des ouvertes,
faut faire des bouquins, hein.
Ouais. Euh alors dans les 3 10 15
prochaines années, ben je crois que si
on ne
si on ne rétablit pas déjà un peu l'État
dans ces prérogatives régaliennes, alors
pas toutes, on a abdiqué notre monnaie.
Donc bon, c'est déjà très lourd comme
dépendance,
mais certainement en matière de défense,
certainement en matière de si vous
voulez pour moi les questions de
politique étrangère et de stratégie,
c'est pas c'est pas le sexe des anges
quoi. C'est quelque chose qui qui a un
impact sur la cohésion de la société
concrète dans laquelle vivent nos
concitoyens.
Donc pour moi c'est c'est très c'est
très vivant et c'est très ordinaire.
Donc comment je vois la France ? Je
pense que si l'État effectivement ne se
reprend pas en main, si on ne fait pas
un certain nombre de réformes très
urgentes, si on n'explique pas aux
français que ils pourront pas tout avoir
pour rien, voilà, ça va plus être
possible.
Si on ne corrige pas effectivement des
très très grandes disparités, trop
lourdes, mais là je parle du 0,01
% et vraiment du bas de notre échelle
sociale. Voilà, là il y a des vrais
problèmes. Au milieu, je moi je crois
oui à détabouiser. Voilà, c'est-à-dire
qu'il faut que les gens puissent bosser,
payer moins d'impôts,
mais aussi avoir un certain nombre de
devoirs.
Je pense aussi que la jeunesse qui
attend que tout lui tombe tout cuit, bah
faut qu'elle comprenne que maintenant
c'est c'est plus la petite France, la
petite c'est c'est le monde entier.
J'ai des enfants, moi j'ai des j'ai deux
fils.
C'est compliqué même à eux de leur faire
comprendre ça. C'estàd une espèce de
on est décontracté quoi. La jeunesse
européenne, elle est décontractée. Mais
les petits chinois pas la même la même
jeunesse européenne
vraiment. Euh euh revenir à ça, les
Français, comment on fait pour leur
faire conscience de de l'aspect
géopolitique ? Comment on fait pour leur
communiquer que des informations ?
Comment on fait pour
les sensibiliser aux questions euh
Mais ce que je fais là, c'est important
de ce point de vue-là, c'est possible
pour ça que je le fais.
Euh
il faut il faut parler, il faut écrire,
il faut essayer d'influer,
il faut essayer d'être d'être pris au
sérieux comme un élément dans un
dispositif
euh de réflexion. Il faut essayer de
leur montrer que la manière dont leur
pays se projette à l'étranger a des
conséquences directes sur leur sécurité.
Euh il faut traiter des enjeux qui
paraissent plus intérieurs et
[grognement] et qui sont des enjeux pas
seulement sécuritaires, qui sont des
enjeux civils et civiques
euh
qui touche à
la coexistence avec les religions,
laïcité, tout ça sont sont des choses
fondamentales. Donc il faut pas les nier
mais en même temps il faut on est on
n'est pas on n'est pas un petit nuage.
La France elle a une histoire quoi. Elle
a elle a plus de 1000 ans d'histoire.
Donc on on ne doit pas se nier sous
prétexte de rentrer dans le magma
indifférencié européen qu'on nous
propose. On doit on doit juste
s'assumer. Les Allemands s'assument très
bien très Mais si ils s'assument de plus
en plus je vous le garantis. Voilà même
militairement.
Les Japonais aussi, les Russes n'en
parlons pas. C'estàd il y a une synthèse
historique. Vous prenez nos programmes
d'histoire
là là où on a en
C'est quand même pathétique. C'est quand
même pathétique.
Voilà. On ne on ne parle plus de rien.
On ne parle plus de rien. Il y a plus de
grandes figures. Mon dieu, quelle
horreur. Les grandes figures ont fait
des morts. Ah d'accord. Bah ouais, c'est
sûr. Oui. Oui. Il y a eu des guerres.
Oui. Nous sommes construits sur des
guerres. Les pays se construisent sur
des guerres. Comment comment vous voyez
le les révolutions oranges ?
Ah,
les révolutions oranges.
Alors,
d'abord lesquels ? Quoi ? Ukraine 2004,
Ukraine 2014, Ukraine
à vous de choisir. euh Georgie. Euh
[soupir] bah si vous voulez euh
il est clair qu'après la fin de la
guerre froide euh les États-Unis et les
puissances européennes majeures sont
entrées dans une phase
de
de volonté de de projection
d'influence et de et de d'accompagnement
au départ de la prise de liberté de des
anciens satellites soviétiques et et
puis après de changement de modification
de de l'écosystème civil et politique de
chacun de ces pays. Donc il s'agissait
de mettre dans chacun de ces pays
des pouvoirs, des équipes en place qui
soient convergentes avec ce qu'on
espérait faire de l'Europe élargie.
Sachant que ce qu'on voulait faire de
l'Europe élargie, c'est quelque chose
qui s'oppose bien
nettement à la Russie. jusqu'à venir lui
chatouiller les orteils.
Ça a plus ou moins marché finalement
jusqu'à l'Ukraine
et l'Ukraine bah c'est pas passé.
C'est pas passé. D'abord parce que la
Russie a eu une décennie 90 terrifiante
de déstructuration totale de de main
mise occidentale
et qu'à un moment donné le pouvoir à
travers la personnalité de Vladimir
Poutine mais c'est bien au-delà de lui,
il y a eu un il y a eu une un sursaut,
une réaction, une reconstruction,
une reconsolidation d'un pouvoir d'État
qui était vraiment mal en point.
Et donc euh quelque chose qui résistait
finalement à cette offensive.
Et l'Ukraine, bah l'Ukraine c'est un
état tampon
et ça devrait le rester franchement.
Et je pense qu'on est allé trop loin.
C'est de la provocation. Voilà. Faire
tomber l'Ukraine dans l'Union européenne
et dans l'OTAN, c'est juste pas
concevable. D'un point de vue russe, si
vous vous mettez à leur place, ça veut
dire que la frontière la frontière russe
est directement il y a plus de il y a
plus rien. Donc il y avait eu des
accords mais verbaux
volent hein. Voilà donc on aurait dû
écrire
euh
il y avait des accords pour que
l'Ukraine reste
reste neutre d'une certaine manière
reste neutre. et le fait de vouloir la
faire basculer dans dans le camp
otanien. Voilà, c'était c'était juste
pas possible. Donc ce qui est arrivé
était je dirais attendu et peut-être
même espéré parce que ça a cristallisé
le
le le le le le la crispation et le et
l'antagonisme
américano russe avec l'Europe au milieu,
avec tous les anciens satellites
évidemment qui eux en tout cas pendant
longtemps jusqu'aux dernières années
pour la plupart étaient farouchement
antirusse he alors maintenant il y en a
certains qui commencent à réfléchir
différemment mais peu quand même dans
l'ensemble si on regarde les Polonais,
les Baltes, enfin donc il y a là il y a
tout il y a tout un tas de petits
chevaux de trois américains
qui ont tout à gagner qui ont eu tout à
gagner un de l'Europe en terme
économique deux de l'OTAN en terme
sécuritaire et qui sont devenus voilà
notre petit glacis soi-disant. Sauf que
là encore quel est l'intérêt de notre
ensemble européen par rapport à la
Russie ? Il est évident que la Russie
est une puissance européenne. Elle est
euroasiatique certes, mais toute sa
partie développée est européenne.
Et stratégiquement, si on voulait faire
un un trépied stratégique, un tabouret
stratégique, comme disait le général de
la Maison Neuve,
un pain charar.
Un quoi ?
Un pain char.
Qu'est-ce que c'est un pain char ?
Un tabouret à trois pieds qui se plie.
Ah ben voilà, un pain charar. Il se
plerait pas trop celui-là. Euh il est
évident que l'Europe doit être le 3è
pied, mais c'est l'Europe dans une
dans une coexistence pacifiée avec la
Russie. Or, qu'est-ce qu'on fait depuis
toujours et certainement depuis depuis
qu'on a quelqu'un en face qui dit pas
toujours oui euh et bien qu'est-ce qu'on
fait ? On on nourrit l'antagonisme par
1000 façons. La liste est longue. Voilà.
Et l'Ukraine, ça a été la serie sur le
gâteau.
Comment vous voyez l'Algérie après
Bouteflica et comment vous voyez la
réaction de la France face à ça ?
Ouais, c'est compliqué parce que
[soupir]
je dirais pas que l'Algérie est un petit
bout de France même encore aujourd'hui.
Mais enfin, nous avons quand même une
communauté très importante.
Nous avons des liens
non seulement historiques bien sûr, mais
économiques. Nous avons des liens pour
le coup sécuritair important des
coopérations.
C'est un grand pays à nos portes qui vit
là aussi dans une espèce de
qui vivait un peu hors du temps. C'estàd
tout le monde savait bien qu'il y aurait
un problème à un moment donné. Donc là
on voit que le chef d'état-major des
armées pousse son
son voilà et essaie de tenter son sa
chance. [grognement] Le problème c'est
tout ce qu'il y a autour, c'est que
qu'est-ce qui va changer ? il suffit pas
de changer un individu. Donc comment je
vois l'Algérie, je pense que ça va être
compliqué, ça va être difficile. La
décennie 90 était terrifiante.
Donc là aussi, la nécessité de maintenir
quand même
[grognement]
une une sécurité pour les Algériens est
quand même très très importante. Après,
c'est un pays effectivement qui doit
être complètement réformé parce que il
ne vit que sur sa rente, il ne développe
rien et il est ça le fragilise
énormément. [grognement] Donc je pense
qu'il faut qu'on soit nous français
extrêmement prudent. Mais moi je crois à
la souveraineté, c'estàdire on n pas
allé dire aux Algériens ce qu'ils ont à
faire, aux Syriens ce qu'ils ont à
faire, au aux libiens ce qu'ils ont à
faire parce que un jour on va venir nous
dire ce qu'on aura à faire. Voilà. Ah
ben oui, ça nous au nez hein parce que
l'Occident s'imagine que il a le
monopole de la de la parole de
l'anathème et et du conseil de la
violence légitime.
De la violence légitime et en tout cas
de la vérité révélée en terme politique
parce que nous sommes la pointe de
diamant, n'est-ce pas, de la démocratie
mondiale. Certes, euh d'accord, c'est
joli, c'est séduisant, mais la
noningérence, ça existe. C'est pas fait
pour les chiens, c'est dans la charte de
l'ONU.
Donc évidemment, tout le problème c'est
que depuis des décennies, les droits des
individus, l'idée de la protection des
populations, enfin il y a eu tout un tas
de concepts qui sont venus à l'appui en
fait du régime change
et de et de l'ingérence. Voilà.
Comment on fait pour résister au spin
doctor ? Comment on rend sa population
plus aguérie
aux techniques des spin doctor de la
communication politicienne pour faire
partir les peuples en guerre ? Comment
on fait ?
Vous pensez à la France ou vous pensez à
certains États ?
Bah les Spin Doctor, ils ont des
C'est quoi spin doctor ? Bah, c'est des
influenceurs qui sont là pour essayer de
créer une réalité de créer une réalité
en fait.
Les armes de destruction massive
par exemple par exemple. Mais alors ça
c'est le c'est le type même de
c'est le type même d'une d'une fake news
pour le coup dont tout le monde savait
qu'elle était fake. Donc si vous voulez
il faut pas oublier
sauf le mec qui tenait le fusil. Non.
Où ? En Irak.
Oui.
L'irakien ou le l'Américain qui est allé
en guerre.
Américain.
Moi, si vous voulez, j'ai beaucoup de
mal. J'ai beaucoup de mal avec ça parce
que c'est tellement énorme. On sait très
bien que la guerre d'Irak, elle a pas
été on ne planifie pas les guerres 3
mois avant ou 6 mois avant, hein. Bon,
la guerre d'Irak, elle a été planifiée
sous Clinton. Ça a commencé dès 98. On
planifie des années en avance dans les
armées. La
Libye, ça a été planifié sous Chiraak ?
Non, ça je pense pas. Non, pour le coup,
je pense pas. Mais nous, on est des
grands rapides. Non, non, [rires]
non, je plaisante, je plaisante mais je
me détends un peu de temps en temps.
Mais euh l'Irak, c'est une vieille
histoire. Donc après qu'on ait trouvé ce
pauvre Coline Powell qui a quand même
qui a qui a qui a noirci son âme à tout
jamais en se prêtant à ce jeu de la
fiole de farine
à l'Assemblée générale des Nations-
Unies ou au Conseil de sécurité, je sais
plus, [grognement]
mais tout était prêt. Mais c'est
toujours comme ça. Le Kosovo, c'est la
même chose. Massacre de Ratchak,
Sarayevo,
Timisoara,
Timy Soara probablement mais là j'étais
petite là, il faut me joker. Je suis je
saurais pas dire vraiment [grognement]
euh les les les C'est la même chose pour
l'entrée en guerre en Bosnie, c'est la
même chose. Marcal 1, Marcal 2. Bon, les
enquêtes qui ont été faites sur la
balistique mais il y a une vérité.
Les attentats les attentats ou les
frappes chimiques en Syrie, c'est quoi ?
C'est vrai, c'est pas vrai ? existé, ça
a pas existé.
Il y en a peut-être qui ont été vous
voulez dire de la part du régime parce
que de la part des des autres, ça on le
sait. Donc mais simplement on ne le dit
pas parce que le
la fake news c'est aussi le le contraste
ou le défaut de ce qui n'est pas dit.
C'est une si vous ne présentez qu'une
partie de la réalité, c'est comme à l'P
est à l'épo Ouest, hein. C'est Oui. Bah
oui. Ah oui, il y a il y a Est qui est
en ruine mais on ne dit pas qui est à
l'intérieur évidemment. et à en revanche
qui se prend des obus on en parle même
pas parce que ça n'existe même pas en
fait. On ne veut pas que ça existe cette
partie de la ville qui survit. Donc tout
est comme ça. Tout est comme ça. Quand
vous voulez faire entrer une population,
il faut une indignation. Il y a eu des
films là-dessus, [grognement] je sais
plus, j'en avais vu un très bon avec pas
Pen, mais euh bon, j'ai oublié. Euh
c'était c'était le ça se passait
justement au Kosovo. Euh bon la manière
dont on construit la réalité pour les
opinions publiques
euh internationale et en tout cas ce
qu'on appelle la communauté
internationale, c'est-à-dire globalement
les pays occidentaux
euh et ceux qui les suivent.
Voilà. Mais là notre problème est aussi
différent. Il faut il faut déjà qu'on
arrête qu'on arrête de se dire qu'on
devient nous français par exemple les
proxy de certains États parce que c'est
quand même ça qui est dramatique c'est
que bientôt nos armées feront la guerre
des autres.
Le ménage des autres ?
Non pas le ménage. Nos armées ne font
pas le ménage des autres.
Question d'internet. Que pensez-vous de
la question du soft power avec par
exemple le cinéma d'Hollywood ?
C'est c'est une évidence. C'est
c'est oui bien sûr ça existe mais ça
c'est l'influence normative mais vous
aurez bientôt les Indiens qui font la
même chose les Chinois le font aussi
enfin je veux dire après c'est une
question de puissance une question de de
moyens aussi énormément mais en France
on résiste un peu quand même.
Vous connaissez un peu la Suède ?
J'y ai toute une branche de ma famille
mais je n'y suis jamais allé.
C'est très bon pays.
Est-ce que vous avez suivi les manœuvres
militaires suédoises récentes ? Non,
dites-moi.
Non, non, juste une question comme ça.
Et ça, ça se balade un peu en ce moment.
Oui.
Est-ce que vous voyez un sujet que vous
voulez aborder avec nous sur la
géopolitique, sur par exemple la finance
? Vous avez pas parlé de de
l'extraterritorialité de du droit
américain ?
C'est un très bon sujet. Il y aurait
tellement de choses dont on pourrait
parler encore. Mais oui, bien sûr. Bah,
l'extraterritorialité, ça c'est aussi
quelque chose qui doit qui doit être
vraiment combattu. Mais là aussi, on est
dans une situation où on n'ose pas quand
on voit la manière dont on s'est retiré
de l'Iran
dont Total quand même qui est un bout de
France a vendu ses parts justement au
Chinois sur Espace. Enfin, c'est là, il
y a des choses qui sont pour moi qui
sont absolument insupportables. Alors,
on me dit "Oui, mais bien sûr, mais nous
risquons de telles amendes, nous
risquons c, nous risquons ça." Bon, on a
certes fait à l'échelle européenne un
véhicule, ce qu'on appelle une espèce de
véhicule pour contourner un peu les
mécanismes de sanction. Je ne sais pas
ce que ça va donner parce que ça m'a
l'air d'être une sacrée usine à gaz. Je
sais même pas si les Iraniens qui
eux-mêmes ont des problèmes sauront s'en
servir.
Ils sont bien rodés à ça.
Ouais. Non, ils sont pas encore bien
rodés du tout à ce système qui est mise
en place. Non, c'est un vrai sujet. Mais
euh il est certain que tant qu'on aura
pas mis,
j'allais dire les deux points sur la
table pour dire ça suffit, euh
vous trouvez que Macron est en train de
le faire là ?
Non, pas particulièrement. Pourquoi il
le ferait ? Comment ? Non, non, non. Ah
non, non, non. Mais ça c'est non parce
que c'est c'est un risque politique très
important mais pour moi c'est en prenant
des vrais risque.
Et on a là on a quand même un momentum
très important depuis que Trump est
arrivé au pouvoir. On a quand même
quelqu'un qui nous explique tellement
tellement bien et tellement nettement
les choses même s'il a de bonnes idées
parce que vous vous souvenez que quand
il est arrivé au pouvoir il avait
proposé un vrai reset avec la Russie. Il
ess il avait compris en fait que la
Chine allait se servir.
Ben ouais mais il avait compris et il a
compris clairement que la Chine allait
se servir de la Russie, allait essayer
de récupérer la Russie dans son Giron et
il s'est dit on va peut-être quand même
essayer de de faire en sorte que ça ne
se produise. Moi je crois que c'est ça
c'était ça l'idée. Je sais pas si c'est
la sienne, si on l'a lui assoufflé, si
son équipe originelle avait ça comme
idée en tête. En tout cas tout le monde
lui a sauté dessus.
Ça risquait de mettre à bas juste
effectivement tout le tout le discours
et évidemment tous les marchés colossaux
d'armement et de construction et de bon
qui sont derrière la diabolisation de la
Russie, ne serait-ce que par rapport à
l'Alliance atlantique mais mais pour
tout dans tout un tas de domaines. Donc
là, il s'est heurté à trop forte parti.
On lui a changé tout son casting quand
même et on l'a noyé pendant 2 ans dans
une espèce de nécessité perpétuelle de
prouver qu'il était pas un agent du
Kremelin. C'est quand même un truc de
fou.
Vous avez vu le la conclusion du la
conclusion du rapport ? On a eu
tr pages.
Ouais. On n pas eu les 420 pages de de
Non mais ça on les aura pas. Non, on ne
les aura pas parce que ne serait-ce que
parce que ça permet au démocrates de
continuer et de dire "Oui, mais
attendez, il y a l'intérieur du rapport,
il faut pouvoir le délivrer, il y a
certaines choses et puis maintenant on
va s'intéresser." De toute façon, on lui
fera pas de cadeau pendant 4 ans.
C'est c'est une c'est une faillite
médiatique.
C'est bien dommage pour l'Amérique hein,
parce que l'Amérique aussi, elle a des
problèmes.
Oui, c'est une faillite médiatique que
l'ensemble de l'appareil médiatique
occidental est chargé sur la collision
Trump. Euh Russie,
c'est une fake médiatique. Non, c'est
une réalité. C'est c'est-à-dire
vous voulez dire que les médias
occidentaux ont suivi CNN ? Bah oui,
bien sûr. Mais c'est c'est c'est
Non, mais c'est c'est effrayant la
manière dont on présente cet homme en
France ou partout. En fait, il suffit
d'être dans un hôtel quelque part, même
si on regarde pas les les chaînes
internationales toute la journée. Moi,
dès que je voyage un peu, c'est c'est
terrifiant. C'est terrifiant. Mais ça
c'est un c'est encore un problème.
C'est-à-dire moi je suis toujours je
suis fatiguée de ce nombre de pseudox
qui blablatent toute la sainte journée
sur les plateaux de télé pour
pour occuper pour occuper le terrain
pour continuer à dire un peu, enfin
juste pour salir un peu pour pour
distyer distyler le fiel. Mais pendant
ce temps, il y a le président des
États-Unis quand même. Lui aussi, c'est
pas très bon pour lui. Je suis pas je
suis pas proaméricaine, je suis pas
anti-américaine, mais si j'étais
américaine,
je trouverais ça assez dommageable pour
mon pays que on passe autant de temps et
autant d'énergie dans ce système
politique soi-disant tellement
merveilleux à juste et autant de fric
aussi, autant d'argent à se battre pour
des trucs politiciens internes. Si je
vous dis état profond, ça vous fait
penser à quoi ?
Bah une réalité
euh dans un certain nombre de pays, pas
pas qu'aux États-Unis.
C'est c'est quoi l'état profond ? l'état
profond euh c'est une c'est la
convergence de plusieurs réseaux en fait
pour moi euh qui mêle à la fois euh les
réseaux bien sûr liés aux services
secrets, au renseignement, [soupir] mais
aussi des réseaux militaires, mais aussi
des réseaux financiers, mais aussi
parfois dans certains pays euh
religieux bien sûr, religieux
[grognement]
euh et aussi parfois un peu lié au
banditisme. Enfin, c'est c'est voilà,
[grognement] c'est une espèce de de
pieuvre mais c'est pas c'est encore une
fois c'est pas non plus du complotisme.
Ce sont des liens et des et des
alliances objectives d'intérêt en fait
euh
sur le dos du vrai peuple.
Ah mais qu'est-ce que le vrai peuple ?
Celui qui gagne pas grand-chose, qui
veut jouer dans les règles du jeu, qui
veut avancer son petit bout de gras
gentiment. euh et qui constate les
ravages que l'État profond et la
politique
prédatrice sur les ressources ont fait à
la planète.
Oui, mais ça c'est vrai, mais c'est pas
nouveau plus.
Et là, ça prend peut-être des
proportions.
Ça prend des proportions parce qu'il y a
une accélération, parce que la
technologie s'en mêle aussi, parce que
il y a
parce qu'il y a une déshumanisation
globale des choses, des phénomènes, des
process parce que parce qu'on sait très
bien même en France que d'ici 10 15 ans,
il y aura quand même un petit tiers de
notre population active qui en fait sera
devenu économiquement inutile. Donc
c'est un vrai sujet ça mais ça c'est le
sujet aussi de des transformations
technologiques. C'est le sujet du
transhumanisme. C'est enfin ça c'est
encore ça pourrait faire l'objet
d'un autre débat tout entier.
On arrête la punition ou on pose encore
quelques questions ?
Moi je je vais bien moi. Donc si vous en
avez d'autres.
C'est long comme le bras d'ailleurs le
des des listes de questions.
Je me sens pas puni d'ailleurs.
Merci.
Non
euh
on on en pose une petite dernière. euh
la politique moyen moyen-orientale avec
Israël, le fait que la toute la région
soit soit déstabilisé.
Euh je vais vous poser une question qui
va sembler très conne. On fait comment
pour pacifier tout ça ? On emmène
l'armée sur le terrain, on fait une
autre Afghanistan, on fait quoi ? On
leur on leur coupe les vivres ? On fait
quoi ? On arrête de leur fournir des
armes ?
On arrête de leur envoyer de l'argent ?
On fait quoi ? Tu
ch coulet ?
Oui, on ne on ne combat pas
on ne combat pas avec des élastiques et
des frondes là-bas. Donc il y a bien des
armes déjà, il y a de la formation.
Israël achète des armes aux États-Unis
mais il y a pas qu'Israël.
La question c'est ce qui est quand même
assez frappant et sur lequel on ne parle
pas finalement ou très peu, c'est la
collusion qui est maintenant ouverte
au nom de la jeunesse
euh d'un prince saoudien
héritier
et de la jeunesse du gendre d'un
président américain
euh qui a des affiliations bien sûr
israélienne. Il y a une collusion
ouverte, assumée, revendiquée
entre les pays sunnites et pas pas les
moindres, l'Arabie Saoudite et Israël,
ce qui était quand même pas le cas
depuis toujours. C'est
c'est des sémites.
Ah ben ça non, mais d'accord. Non,
sunnite. Sunnite, j'ai dit, hein.
Arabie Saoudite et Israël, c'est bien
sûr. Non, mais bien sûr. Mais enfin,
jusqu'à présent, Israël était censé se
se protéger du monde arabe dans son
ensemble. Or là, on voit bien que le
lien est net. Maintenant, le lien Tel
Aviv Washington
Riad ou Riad Washington,
il est clair, il est voilà. Euh
[grognement] et donc on a un vrai
problème. On a le problème de la guerre
du Yémen, on a le problème de de On a le
problème de l'Iran. Alors là aussi, je
pense qu'il y a peut-être un mot à dire
sur peut-être la solution. On a
peut-être la solution avec l'Iran.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez ? Qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de donner de l'arme
nucléaire à l'Iran pour pacifier la
région ?
Pacifier, je ne sais pas. Il faudrait
déjà qu'elle se calme. Euh moi je pense
que euh il faut pas oublier que l'arme
atomique c'est une arme de
sanctuarisation.
Voilà. Donc si Saddam Husin avait eu
l'arme atomique, il sera encore làin.
Bon donc ça c'est une réalité. Après que
les pays qui ont proliféré et nous
sommes parmi les premiers et Israël
[grognement] aussi et cetera, nous avons
tous été des proliférateurs. Veuille
fermer le club. On peut comprendre
simplement, on comprend moins pourquoi
par exemple le Pakistan, lui il a la
bombe. Ça alors là en terme de de de
menace sécuritaire, c'est quand même
c'est quand même assez angoissant. Le
Pakistan, moi ça m'angoisse beaucoup
plus que l'Iran, personnellement.
Ensuite, la rivalité Iran Israël,
pour moi, elle n'est pas militaire parce
que c'est vraiment l'éléphant et la
souris quoi militairement. Bon, elle est
c'est bien plus important que ça parce
que finalement alors
qui l'éléphant qui est la souris ?
Ben l'éléphant c'est Israël et la souris
c'est l'Iran en terme en terme de
défense, en terme de de capacité de
frappe, de capacité de représaillement.
Le vrai problème, c'est que les Iraniens
et les Israéliens sont les mêmes.
Et c'est un général du Shinbet dont
j'oublie toujours le nom, mais on le
retrouve sur le net. qui il y a quelques
années avait été avait été interviewé,
je me souviens plus dans quel cadre et
il a dit trois quatre lignes que j'ai
quelque part disant le danger d'Israël
n'est pas militaire. Le danger c'est
qu'ils sont comme nous, très éduqués,
très intelligents, culturellement
très ancien enfin avec une histoire.
Mais bon euh industriellement mais si
mais si
le ça la concurrence elle est là pour
moi. Elle est là c'est-à-dire que le
jour où l'Amérique change son fusil
d'épaule ce qui peut arriver parce
qu'elle le change aussi de temps en
temps ou elle le diversifie et elle l'a
fait en Iran pendant des années et se
dit maintenant je mise sur l'Iran parce
que l'histoire de l'extraterritorialité
c'est clair. Il s'agit de congeler le
marché iranien jusqu'au moment où ils
vont décider que c'est pour eux. Voilà.
Donc ça c'est c'est un avantage
concurrentiel. C'est voilà leur
extraterritorialité leur sert d'avantage
concurrentiel. Donc le jour où l'Iran
redevient une cible économique légitime
si on ne le détruit pas d'ici là ou si
on narrive pas à le détruire mais à mon
avis on y arrivera pas.
Euh et bien à ce moment-là, Israël va
avoir là pour le coup forte affaire,
c'est-à-dire le véritable, on nous dit
toujours, c'est l'Arabie Saoudite contre
l'Iran, les Sunnites, les Chites, mais
la confessionnalisation bien sûr, elle
existe mais elle est largement nourrie
entretenue. Elle est elle est nourrie
parce qu'elle sert à masquer d'autres
problèmes, des problèmes énergétiques,
des problèmes politiques et voilà.
On arrive à la fin.
Oui.
Euh, vous avez trois livres à conseiller
à notre communauté.
Ah, j'aurais dû y penser. Oui. Euh,
j'ai oublié le titre du dernier de bray.
Non, pas le dernier, l'avant-dernier.
Alors, il y a Conte à rebour du
Bervéine, son dernier.
Il y a un vieux bouquin, mais tout y
est, sur le rasie, sur la domination de
leur Asie du côté américain qui est le
livre de Sbign Brezinski qui s'appelle
Le grand échiquier. Ça c'est à lire.
La guerre hors limite de mes deux
colonels chinois dont j'ai oublié les
noms. Euh, qu'est-ce que je pourrais
vous conseiller d'autres ? Et
l'avant-dernier de Break qui dit
"Pourquoi ? Pourquoi on est devenu
américain ou comment on est devenu
américain ? Je me souviens plus du
titre." Voilà qu'il lit ça et puis un
jour je vais peut-être arriver à
terminer le mien.
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? une bouteille à la
mer, quelque chose d'impérissable,
quelque chose qui va rester sur le le
réseau.
Douter et voyager.
Caroline Galacteros, merci,
je vous en prie. C'était un plaisir.
Plaisir partagé.
[musique]